You're fucking freaks.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com,
which is right now,
the only way Brian sells those,
those,
uh,
kittycat tee shirts that you see,
those death squad shirts from death squad.tv.
He actually uses stamps.com so we know it's a good product.
If you use the code word Jre,
there's a little microphone in the upper right hand corner was old school.
He microphones for whatever reason,
that's like the cool microphone.
I don't know why I never got that,
but regular microphones don't get nearly enough fucking credit.
There's something sexy about those old school Frank Sinatra in the 1930s back
when people were dumb as fuck.
That was a really awesome microphone.
So it's like a talk shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's classy.
Uh,
if you click on that and entering the code word j r e,
it was a special offer.
You get all kinds of cool shit,
like a free scale and 80 bucks and $25 in postage coupons.
And if you look at the website,
go to,
um,
go to stamps.com and then click on the thing and entering the code word jre.
It'll fill you in on all the details.
Uh,
about the,
uh,
the opera w the way it is.
It says,
I have it says $110 bonus offer.
Why does it say $80?
Because he normally just a normal person that goes to stamps.com he only gets
that $80 a offer.
But if you've typing or you click on that microphone and type in j Rue,
you get a even better off.
Then you get $110.
I got confused.
I was like,
did they lower it?
I hate it when people like lower it,
you know,
when they have like,
I don't want to call them out on it because there are our customers or were you
know,
their customers or something like that working together.
Yeah.
Uh,
anyway,
if you go to stamps.com but it allows you to do is you measure all your shit.
Like,
say if you say it,
sell things like,
you know,
send things online.
You measure all your shit at home,
you put your little sticker on it,
boom.
Postman picks it up.
You don't have to go to the mailbox.
You'd have to wait in line.
You'd have to weigh your shit.
You could do it all right there.
Print up your own postage and be done with that whole process.
Use The code word J,
r e and save yourself some money aren't your Fox were also brought to you by
onnit.com that's o.
if you haven't been to the website,
we don't know what the fuck to call the company.
So we call it a human performance enhancement company,
if that makes any sense.
Human Performance Company,
uh,
the whole company is just focused on shit that makes your body work better.
Uh,
exercise equipment that's the best for functional strength,
nutritional supplements that are passed for recovery and for cognitive function
and endurance and all that shit.
Very,
uh,
all of it is very healthy stuff.
It's like whatever we feel like we would buy whatever we feel like we would use.
And I think,
you know,
it's beneficial as far as like exercise equipment or vitamins or supplements.
That's the kind of stuff we sell and we just try to sell you the best shit we
can find.
And if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you saved 10% of any and all supplements.
Any,
any shows coming up?
Uh,
yeah,
I'm going to be a at,
not to Braya,
but what's the other one?
Ontario.
No,
no.
Braya I'm going to be in Bray Bray Improv.
What are you doing?
Improv and going to Toronto next month and a comic con 2013 all the shit can be
found at [inaudible] dot TV or my Twitter is red ban and all my shit.
That's a,
all my a upcoming dates are all on Joe rogan.net all right,
that's,
let's just bail on this everlasting here.
Goddammit.
Commercial is now officially over
[inaudible]
stab lab.
Now,
Rod Gangsta Lean,
she
got a stick on a Mama.
The tattoos
seen as she was pushing the stroller,
smoke.
No cigarette drinking a Saluda
lab.
Nat,
a jewel,
Betas name tattooed on the back of the shoulder,
top
black devil
number tattooed.
See here,
east side of the city,
Rau.
I'm in both.
She don't
got no,
I'll show the crowd
now.
Bag of groceries.
Zane post office,
man,
she's Santa's little money and she made him sweat.
A phone is
most litigious,
matte black and sales should bang.
She says
she never Bam Solon alone.
No,
she got Megan.
She's girl.
Common mad girl of the Tattoo to you.
Yeah.
Snag Rau.
Woman.
Bolshie
no
sag.
Who got
me?
Oh,
shoulder
back to me.
She's a sad girl cause man,
no man.
Powerful.
So great to have you back,
man.
That was awesome.
Thank you sir.
Did a wine but Lasko joining me.
Brian.
It's up high.
You Doing Gentlemen Javelin?
You know this is a strange times.
It's good to have a man like Everlast around trying to be,
trying to think,
trying to make it happen.
These are strange times,
my friend every day.
How are You Ben?
Good.
Live in Levin.
Yup.
Dan Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
I'm surrounded my crazy women.
That's how I've,
you know,
if you could say that you've probably had a fun life.
I'm surrounded by and completely insane women with the ones that I'm not crazy
or not fun to be around unfortunately.
Just had a new one,
you know?
Got a three month old at home graduations,
ma'am.
Thank you.
Yeah,
everything's going good man.
Um,
you know,
just,
just turned rambling mines as well.
Has it been a year?
It's probably been about a year.
Yeah.
Somewhere around there.
Last time.
Too Long.
Yeah.
This is the first time at this place to made an acoustic record.
We're going to have just because of y'all rarely.
That's ridiculous.
When does that come out?
Um,
like August sometime.
I don't have the exact date,
but y'all will have it.
You know what I mean?
So you started doing acoustic shows,
you know,
I would do acoustic stuff,
like,
like walk in the radio station,
promote your record.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And then like,
um,
came and did your podcast first time,
didn't do any music and I mean,
people were still super love,
you know what I mean?
And then that second time when I came and did music the first time and kind of
busted the cherry and the Joe Rogan show in the musical world also,
you did,
you know,
like the reaction was ridiculous,
man.
I mean,
we've been doing coke,
Cousteau tours,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like it's literally like we toured all the Europe and the winter and sold out a
lot of shows.
There's a lot of Joe Rogan lovers in Europe too,
man.
But you know,
man,
there's,
there's something really cool about acoustic music.
There's something really cool about when you're doing a song and it's just you
and your guitar and that's it.
You now or in,
in a keyboard back up or whatever.
When you're right there doing it live and raw like that on a,
on an internet radio show,
it's all just,
broadcast is no stop.
There's no,
let's try this again and let's get it from the top.
When you drill down and it's just a good,
the way it says something about a us,
a sing,
a real singer songwriter and a guitar.
It's one of the purest forms of expression.
The way it like hits you like emotional impact of songs.
A dude with a guitar with a voice like yours and a guy who was always writing.
That's when I dig about you.
You're always writing.
You've always got new shit.
You're always coming in here with new songs.
You always have like you're always working,
man.
You were just always putting in the work when it comes to you
music.
You know what I mean?
It,
I mean you make people laugh,
you go look for crazy shit.
You know what I mean?
Something you're so tells you you got to do.
Yeah.
You could make some money at it as the bonus is the,
but uh,
there is the artist side of it that it's like if I don't wake up and hustle
something out of nothing out of thin air,
you know,
then rent might not get paid in six months.
That's true too.
And we've all seen people drop off.
It's scary.
Once you're moving,
you've got to keep moving once you know,
more money,
more problems.
You know,
one other thing is I said something to Irish,
whole lot of fucking problems.
Yeah.
Anybody who doesn't want those problems,
don't be silly.
They're better than the starving problems.
I was telling the army should fear that.
You know,
we were talking about like writing material and we just,
in the middle of the conversation,
I'm realize I'm like,
you know,
if you're an Ra ship for your fan,
you're the only one who could deliver it.
Like it's your responsibility.
You have like thousands of Ari Shaffir fans,
but you're the only one who can deliver you like you a particular style of
comedy.
You are what you look like,
the way you speak.
It's either the only one,
this is it.
So like for someone who's an Everlast fan,
you're the only one.
There's no other,
there's no other Everlast out there.
You the only guy who can produce Everlast material.
So that's like a giant responsibility.
And if you're a fan,
you want to tap into a dude is always creating new shit,
you know,
that way,
if you become a junkie,
like if you're a Leonard Skinner Junkie,
fuck man to sit,
they,
you know,
that fucking plane crash was a long ass time ago.
But if you're an Everlast fan,
you're always begging out new shit.
You know,
we work in trying to be like,
you man.
I don't even know what that means,
but thanks.
I'm not even trying to be like me.
I'm just trying to make sense of the whole fucking thing.
Cancer.
Have you seen the,
uh,
the thing that's going down right now in Turkey?
Do you know what's happened to the riots?
Rebellion.
Massive rebellion and Turkey.
I have not read much about it.
Uh,
this,
it's,
they're saying it's some sort of like an occupier style revolt and I saw a photo
of a,
these people walking down the street and it's insane.
It's like some end of the world.
Shit.
It's like Brian,
see if he could pull up the picture.
It's crazy.
This picture of these people were walking down the street together.
I mean,
it was overflowing with people.
It's like everyone was out there marching in protests.
It was like 100% of the people in the city and seeing them walking down the
street.
It's,
it's fucking craziness,
man.
I don't exactly know what the fuck the story as though.
It's kind of strange to me too.
It's like,
I mean,
I don't know what,
maybe it's just my perception of things,
but it seems like the less we are like that,
like our country that used to be that kind of country where there'd be,
we got in an uproar.
They protested.
You know that though.
I mean it happens but let's keep it real.
It doesn't happen.
Like using the more,
the rest of the world takes advantage of their freedom.
Like the less we actually use ours at all.
Well I think we're just so soft.
It's so sad when you're by like,
you know,
powdered donuts at 3:30 AM you know,
at the Ralph's every other block.
It's,
yeah,
life gets easy.
It's,
that's not good for you to be,
for things to be that easy,
you know?
That's why like an easy job.
It's probably one of the worst things you should ever,
you know,
you don't want an easy job.
You don't want something that you could just have brain it,
you will slowly rot away while these kids in Turkey or throwing Molotov
cocktails at the cops and trying to take over the government.
You know those are,
it's like,
but it's always going to be that,
right.
We wishing good luck to them or not.
That's the,
I said I'm not,
I don't know what I'm going to go.
I'm going to go with yes.
Just because I'm a rebel.
I'm down with that.
Brian,
are you a rebel?
I am ready to go with,
yes.
Awesome.
We're done with the younger,
you have a bomb on your hat.
So funny by the way,
and being on the airplane with his hat was really uncomfortable.
I forgot that I had it on and it's just like writing after the Boston bombings
too.
And I was like,
why am I wearing this kind of taste?
Good choice.
Did you have the Cammo jacket to go with it?
No.
Like a hunting.
Like a duck.
The duck dynasty,
like hunting jams
with an empty scabbard.
Yeah.
Check my sword.
Jesus.
What about those fucking guys that just hacked the dude up and Oh yeah,
in England.
That to me was like,
what the fuck is wrong with?
And hope it's really crazy.
If you seen the video of the guy talking to the camera.
I didn't hear the talking about the image but I didn't hear any of that.
What?
Like the rant or anything?
Yeah.
I don't know what happened man.
But apparently it was something to do with religion.
Yeah,
that's,
I'm kind of know distant from religion.
I used to experiment and all kinds of them.
I don't reject any blue or a Muslim for a while.
Why am I mean?
I won't,
I don't,
you know,
I,
I don't practice cause I just don't believe in organized religion at this point.
Right.
I believe,
I do believe in God and I believe in a single creator and all that.
Damn.
But there's a lot of stories I don't believe in magic.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Well,
you know what I think about religion.
You know,
when I was a young man,
I was forced into Catholics and I don't believe in killing motherfuckers because
my shit is right and yours is wrong.
You know what I mean?
Unless it's you're breaking into my house trying to steal my shit then then I'm
a fair.
You're fair game.
Well,
when I,
when I was a kid I was forced to go to Catholic school and I hated religion for
a long time after that and just thought it was ridiculous.
The nuns were cons.
It was a mess.
It was just,
I was raised Catholic.
I got a story to it.
Did you go to Catholic school?
Yeah,
so I've,
I've for longest time,
yeah,
go ahead.
I'm sorry for the line is time.
After that I thought that religion was horse shit.
You know,
I thought this is nothing in this.
But then as I got older I realized that it's just because I had a terrible
experience with it.
And if you look at like a lot of the principles of religion,
you got to decipher the fact that people been around for so long just telling
stories and by the time it gets written on paper or people's try to twist
things,
they're the way that they would like it to be when it comes to translations and
things like that.
And it goes in different languages.
But the core of it all,
it's like people trying to figure out how to get along to connect.
Yeah.
People trying to figure out how to express love.
People trying to figure out how to,
how to treat one as you would like to be treated.
You know like literally the tenants for life that people figured out before they
really knew much of anything about how the world works.
They had these ideas and they said they came from God.
You know,
and whether or not anybody had one on one experience with God.
I don't know.
I mean mate Shit,
who the fuck knows it's there.
Just the at the earth exists at all.
It's pretty fucking crazy as far as I'm concerned.
It's nuts.
But I mean,
I compare it to this.
It's like I,
I don't say I know anything about a god.
I have a sense that there's a higher power.
I have a sense of it,
you know,
I feel like I do.
I feel like there's something there.
But can I understand it or explain it or define it now man.
Cause you know,
I always say,
you know,
somebody wants told me that's like your shoe defining you.
Right.
You know,
there's gotta be a line before between whatever a creator is.
And when the creation,
I don't even assume it human characteristics anymore.
I just take it as like,
you know,
kind of like whatever energy I'm following.
I never,
I never went to school for music.
You would to tell I was,
I never planned to do any of this shit with my life.
And I don't say go around.
I'm not preaching or anything,
but I'm saying alls I did was follow a certain path in energy and led me through
every religion.
It led me through every religion and by the time I got to Islam,
Aye.
I took it into my life and it's primarily about peace and love.
And then there's all this other sub cultural crazy stuff that goes on in these
other places.
I approached it from a Western mind in a western philosophy of like just this is
a philosophy to deal with.
It's not like my,
my clan didn't get murdered by that guys Emam 14,000 or 1400 years ago.
You know,
there's all these sub stuff that goes on between these Sophie's and Sunni's and,
and that's when I was like,
you know what?
Organized religion as a whole is garbage because it meant they're just
organization to it.
Somebody in charge and then there's power struggle.
Yeah.
Whenever you put it in individual vantage,
religion should be mine.
It's not even up for discussion.
And last,
we're going to sit there and be like very,
you know,
unless there's no,
I sat down with you.
I know we could sit down and have a cool conversation,
but you know,
there's also 400,000 people that listen to this or of millions of people that
listen to this and,
and you know,
you can't have a reasonable argument with every single one at the light.
You know,
I think that the idea of the organization,
like when you put something into a giant organization,
then you set rules up.
All of a sudden things get weird,
you know,
that's when people get into power and its influence gets manipulated and,
and the,
you know,
like I tell people all the time,
you can consider me Muslim,
but I'll go out,
I'll go out tonight,
which you and we'll drink three whiskeys.
I don't care what you eat,
bank.
And what will you meet Allie?
Pepperoni.
Yes,
I will.
You know,
my wife,
that's my wife,
the half Jewish lady,
uh,
you know,
reintroduced pepperoni's into the life.
So I made a moderation recently to the lyric was I'll never eat a pig and less a
pig as a cop.
So it Kinda just,
it leaves a little open door.
I was in Seattle and some lady came to the show and gave me venison,
pepperoni that she had made with venison.
Her husband was a deer hunter.
God Damn,
it was good.
There was so much of it.
I ate it all.
We see you throwing shit on the grill on Instagram and I just haven't got that
call ever.
Like,
come on,
have some of his venison steak with me and my underwear two o'clock in the
morning and just being out there with nature,
that's my,
you know,
my mind is my real time.
My spare tire man.
You know what I put,
I bought,
I posted a picture reasonably like a Willie Nelson,
like on oh my.
That was like,
man.
And I'd looked at it afterwards and I was just,
man,
I look so young and Dan and go,
I gotta drop like to Apple.
Even hashtagged it on there.
I got to drop like 20 pounds.
I meant to ask you this,
you're,
you have this artificial valve and your heart.
Does that prevent you from doing any kind of actual reasonably Joe?
My Engineer Guy,
one of my entourage,
he's that guy hard into [inaudible] and uh,
and he was doing P90x in the morning and,
and insanity at night.
And that guy right there,
Tam.
So like he got me kind of pumped up.
I started,
I went from p nine Dx,
it lasted about one day.
And then I went to my doctor because it discouraged me.
I was like Yo.
And he just,
I got it.
I got to find a dude who like,
I'm interested in your guy who's coming in here and a couple of days that the
fitness dude,
oh I need to find dude,
he knows how to build my,
my,
my heart back up to that level of output.
Cause it right now it's not there and I can't just get on a treadmill.
It's boring.
I'd rather play basketball and he's someone who's going to make it fun,
make it interesting and bright.
And then also,
you know,
keep me from eating fucking Lorna Doones at like two 30 and does the valve,
does the valve function like normal car?
Except for like 2025 pounds that he don't like.
I'm healthy as an ox.
Right.
Oh,
okay.
So you could do anything.
So if I got there,
you know what you should do man,
he should take martial arts,
take a martial law,
was doing Jujitsu and stuff and then it's like I kind of put this weight on when
my doctor mind,
I won't blame my daughters,
we had this like a lot of her life is pumping calories into her,
like keeping weight on cystic fibrosis.
Youngsters is important for their lung development.
So like everything in our house is extra fat in it.
And for a long time I just Anna and hey,
I mean I won't lie.
The department,
you know,
you go through depressions and you know your food is an outlet.
You've got snack a little too much sometimes.
But food is yummy.
It's delicious.
The problems so good.
But you know,
so you know,
I just wound up putting on weight.
What was the question there?
When I went into my second and my daughter and it's a whole nothing we just
talking to about what?
Martial arts you said.
Oh yeah I was doing Jujitsu.
Yeah.
And then after I put this weight on,
I went,
I tried to go back and it's like with a spare tire trying to do hip throw.
You got it.
Yeah man.
You know I was like no I got it.
I got to do that.
I got to drop some pounds to get back just so I can drop some pounds.
It's just treated as like an,
I mean you should probably get in shape before you do it,
but you could treat it as some sort of a mental exercise.
Fire Yourself.
There's some torn.
If I make that move I was telling you about,
you know,
I'll probably,
I'll be able to hit the Runyon canyon run and walks and stuff like that.
That's always fun.
I liked that walk.
It's getting up to the top is a reward.
It's huge.
I actually used to pull up and start at the top and walked down cause then you
got to come back up and get your car.
You know what I mean?
Caffeine and Jack Daniels also helps with weight loss.
If you throw up a lung Caner,
this was amazing.
It was just terrible for weight loss.
That's horrible.
It's just sugar.
Yeah it is.
Unfortunately because of I drink whiskey,
it turns right into sugar.
How weird.
I'm not hastily.
I can't give that up.
I need to guy who's going to show me how I can work around some of the feet.
I think that it's,
it's all about moderation,
you know?
I don't think you have to give up the whiskey.
I think if you want to stay.
Another thing is I stay steady.
I don't,
I I like,
I don't pass a certain point.
You know what I like to 60 and it's like oh that's the,
that's it.
That's too big.
Then you get mad.
I get mad but I never,
I don't go like to like to 90 or 300 I did once I think like two 90 way back.
Like,
wow.
But a lot of it too is like we were talking about thyroid earlier.
I,
after my surgery I have to take a thyroid pill to like keep my,
my,
my metabolism just kinda just went when all the surgery and stuff happened,
my body just kind of said we're going to slow life down.
Yeah.
I would imagine that heart surgery.
So I just need to find out how I can build back up.
I don't even need to do 90 x like full blast like that,
but I didn't know what I'm saying.
But it's good because it makes you do it.
Yeah.
If you're going to eat it,
it seems like it's too much then,
then you know,
do as much as you can and then stop button.
Yeah.
But it makes you do it.
Whatever.
You're going to find the dude that's going to take money to help me.
I'm sure
he could find it.
You guys going show up at my door and be like,
Yo dude,
get out of bed pussy.
You want someone bad like that.
That was going to be your willpower.
Then we'll,
you know,
we'll be fighting and he's probably going to be in much better shape for me.
So I'm going to have to break out a bat and it's like an assault charge and I
got to buy him a car when I should have just,
I got in shape,
get Richard Simmons banding,
smoke a bunch of and have Richard Simmons help you out.
That sounds like the best thing ever.
You won't feel threatened by him.
You would get to make your heart grow.
Cause he's so heartwarming.
I think you just created the greatest reality show ever.
Wow.
The greatest reality show as I might even,
I might even say yeah to that
if that's all it was about [inaudible] I don't think he would ever would bust a
move.
Come on now it's time's gone.
You know,
maybe when he was younger maybe it would have felt it and felt confident.
Just give you a gentle patter.
The ass.
Every Saturday he does a class in La that you could actually sign up for.
So I'm sure he's up for,
I'll go grab me some dolphin shorts,
man.
That's right.
Get in there,
son.
Don't be scared to tease.
Don't be scared to give them a little tease and you know,
like coke and fucking and,
and,
and Sushi and I don't mean Coca Cola by the way.
Oh,
I know.
I like steak and cheese subs.
Yeah,
I'd love steak,
steak and cheese.
So,
so good.
Steak and cheese sub with a good Italian roll.
Oh,
sweet.
Jesus.
I know it's bad.
Where are you getting that from?
All sorts of different places got hooked me out with,
do you ever go to Kava?
Gretta's you want to get some,
some serious Italian food that you really should never be eaten?
Cavarretta retinas and uh,
I guess it's in Canoga Park.
It's an old school Italian Deli.
God Damn Dude,
they got a sausage and peppers.
It's um,
I don't remember.
I know how to get there,
but it's one of those things where you take a left on there and go right on
there.
And,
um,
Cavarretta is Google it people.
I'll be there.
This is the news of Michael Douglas.
A throat cancer affect your pussy.
Eating at all is a little shocking.
A little shocking,
you know,
I mean,
cause I could swear I heard it a long time ago.
Like he first blamed it all on that kind of already suspected it.
Maybe.
Maybe,
but I heard about just yesterday,
I was first time I heard,
I just heard it yesterday and we're talking about in a while ago
on something.
Hmm.
Maybe.
Maybe it's just that the,
maybe the media,
you know,
it's picking up on it.
The second run around,
you know,
maybe you talked about it before,
but it's a recent thing because,
uh,
a lot of people think that it apparently that it was like cigarettes or alcohol.
He sat HPV and his throat.
Right.
Brian don't do that.
That's just rude.
What was that?
Put a Photoshop of them.
Let's face off photo shopped Michael Douglas.
Plus he works on his face.
That's just rude.
That's is that already is,
but yes,
that's the chief claim.
Yeah,
that's,
it's,
you know,
it's kind of fucked up that sex can give you diseases.
Like what a stupid,
shitty little fucking trick by nature that sex eating pussy can give you some
horrible throat cancer.
Well rude and what sex is most chicks isn't like HPV.
Something like most girls have or most guys have huge percent of the population
has it.
Apparently they can just recently they can,
um,
they can give you a vaccination fraud,
but the vaccinations apparently are a little scary,
aren't they?
Just there for the girls,
right.
Young girls get stacks and there was somewhere where it's a controversial with
her trying to make the girls like somebody was trying to make girls get them
like or make it mandatory.
Ooh,
wow,
that's crazy.
And then they give you a inoculations vaccinations for kids.
They,
one of them to give you is a hepatitis B,
which is a,
I think mostly that's actually transmittable I think.
And you've given it to like kids,
you know,
it's like how many people get hepatitis B and now it's like,
a lot of them are just from sex.
You know,
like maybe it's something that the kid needs to worry about eventually,
but when it,
but when it's a baby,
are we sure that hepatitis,
I just remember being told when I was young,
sex without love was unhealthy.
Really.
Who told you that crazy ass hole doesn't want to have fun?
I can't remember.
Crazy.
Fuck my mother.
Oh silly mom.
It can be both.
Sex with love is best know sex without love is pretty fucking good sex.
It's nothing wrong with it.
People,
if not it needs to be the same.
But the connection,
there's a connection there.
Yeah.
If you know,
if you love somebody,
probably care enough and more about them to find out whether or not,
but,
but at certain numbers it's like the sex without the love is more than a rushed
state.
Right.
Let's just go,
come on.
You know,
I don't care.
They don't speak English.
Do you remember when everybody was worried about AIDS?
I do.
You know what?
I was just saying something about it the other day,
like weird.
Like you know,
it's nobody worries about it.
Oh,
show wasn't I just telling you other day,
like in the nineties like when you're out of that five days when you had to
wait,
even if you knew you were cool,
you were like five days.
You are.
We had to wait for the test to come back.
You were still
hold on or this and you know,
dude,
that's no joke.
It's like not even in this kind of thinks about it.
I remember I was in my car and I was driving to the gym and I was listening to
the radio and Nace I've remembered the fucking the street I was turning on when
they said Magic Johnson just announced that he's HIV positive was home.
I was thinking this shit was the Zombie apocalypse.
I was like him going on the radio and saying he's HIV positive.
Oh my God.
Magic Johnson,
one of the greatest basketball players of all time.
We're all going to die.
I was like,
he's got hates.
Holy Shit.
It's common man.
I would,
I just anticipated a wave of AIDS.
He said never arrived.
Change.
Strange.
Strange,
strange.
I remember when he died of aids and I was like,
wow,
cause that one,
nobody even knew about it until he was dead.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And these people that are dying of AIDS in Africa.
That's a really fascinating thing as well because,
um,
apparently someone please tweet me,
and correct me if this is incorrect,
but
what I've was told was that a lot of what they see when they release figures,
like,
you know,
x amount of people have aids,
that doesn't mean x amount of people or even HIV positive.
That means that they have the symptoms of aids.
It means their immune system is fucked.
So they see these people in,
whether it's from poor nutrition or a host of various diseases,
they don't necessarily test every one of these people because it's expensive to
do that.
So apparently when you hear x amount of people have aids,
that's a little on the rough side.
It's a little bit of a rough estimate.
What,
you know,
it's just people are fucked.
It's a shit spot to be,
there's a lot wrong with being there.
There's a lot of fucking diseases.
It's not just a,
you know,
HIV like,
Goddamn Africa's got a host of fucking diseases,
especially when you're poor and you're not eating anything.
And then like I remember seeing something on a show once about like there was
some certain tribe or area of Africa where the believe the cure for aids,
what's to fucking version,
which is like,
wow,
oh,
how do you even come up with that?
Africa is still rock,
some really crazy ways of life.
It gives you insight into the way the world was just a thousand years ago or
2000 years ago.
Like witchcraft is huge in Africa,
which craft and burning people because they're witches and accusing people of
witches and people doing things to help cure you of demonic possession.
There's like a big business in it where they like cure children of demonic
possession and they,
they,
they take them from their parents and their required,
their parents come up with thousands and thousands of dollars to give to them.
So the parents go fucking crazy and do anything they can to get the money to get
their children back because this guy's claiming that this child is possessed by
the devil.
So if he doesn't do this exorcism,
like they'll kill this kid like this.
It's a a normal common thing in Africa.
I remember seeing something about that fucking crazy.
There's a,
and there's a ton of them and they're all running this racket scare the fuck out
of everybody killing people and it's,
it's an,
it's a naughty place to live
and it's 2013 man.
Just like,
you know,
we're sitting here chilling in the valley,
having ourselves a good old time drinking coffee,
kicking back,
playing music.
This is dude out there is like burning people because he says there are a,
which you know that's all going on somewhere.
Yeah,
it's nutty.
It's Nutty as fuck or moving there.
Don't go to African
people tried.
There was a bunch of Europeans are going to start a wildlife preserve.
I think it's going to preserve itself just fine.
I don't know if you really need to preserve it,
you need to stop people from killing them.
People where people are always killing him for like hard on pills,
you know,
it's always Chinese people that think that you can get some Rhino Horn grinds it
up and you dick grows some tiger penis.
That's ridiculous.
That's what,
that's what,
what else?
There's some other benefits for Rhino Horn or other uses that they use,
but that's what they're killing these rhinos for it.
They're like wiping out the white vinyl population and because people in Asia
have this thing for rhino horns,
it's kind of,
it would kind of suck if there was no more rhinos.
Rhinos are kind of bad ass.
The fact that that thing actually,
there's gotta be thin at this point though.
It must be very thin.
I think some of them are actually extinct now because these dudes just won't
stop hunting them.
They don't give a fuck.
It's just this is,
they live wild.
That's a wild place.
We're so,
so off on that same thing.
I loved cater hunters,
man.
I love all people.
I want to go,
yeah,
I want to go.
I want to go with some pros.
I don't want to go and just try and kind of gator.
I want to be one of the themes and like just even being,
the boat's got to be an adrenaline.
I'd like 12 foot gate or on a boat.
Fuck
those dudes got to be strong as fucking oxys.
The one family,
the son and the dad,
they'll their bill young dudes with that crazy accident.
The Dad's got a rat tail that it was like supposedly like the world champion arm
wrestler in his weight class.
I believe it.
I bet that guy's drunk as fuck.
He's a son,
supposedly fights a little in me,
man.
That's Ron dinosaurs around all day.
I mean the literally pick it up dinosaurs and shoot him in the head.
In the original season of swamp people,
there was a dude that would go out and live,
catch them for like experience like scientists wanted to go.
You've got the medium sized ones but still water by their necks and he would be
like,
tape.
Wow,
crazy.
Love that shit.
How do you get good at that?
Those are the people that are going to be around when it all goes bad still.
You know that right?
Well if you want to go to Louisiana,
you can be around too.
They're everywhere.
Those fucking,
you can't kill the alligators enough like there's,
you have to really go on an assault.
Those guys are pulling 500 out of season.
They still got,
yeah,
he's still got alligators all over the place.
Crossing highways and shit.
They're disgusting.
That must be rough and a dog around there.
Fuck yeah it is.
I,
when I lived in Florida,
dog got stolen from some old lady.
That alligator just
go rack doggy every right to that.
His mind,
their gallery that's not stolen as the rules of the word dog was slipping.
Not only is it Doug slip and it was tied to a chain.
There was an old lady who can't run other end and that's just dinner.
Yeah.
The Florida one of the alligator recognizes the old lady couldn't run.
I wonder because it just came out of the water.
It's like,
Yep,
I'll take that Mac.
Cause she's lucky it took the dog.
She's very lucky,
but they're weird.
They're,
they'd very rarely attack people.
Although there was a story recently where a guy was running from the cops.
It was on a,
in Miami and he,
uh,
hit the brakes and jumped off an overpass into the water right where an
alligator was.
So literally as he jumped into the water,
the alligator attacked him and killed him right in front of the cops.
Probably got jumps off a fucking bridge and lands on you.
The alligator just fucked him up.
The cop said it was like a scene in the movie.
It's like the guy literally locks up his brakes,
jumps into the water,
and then it's,
ah,
alligators are just ripping them apart.
But other than that,
it's pretty rare that they get people crazy crocodiles with what we've got to
worry about.
They have a,
they found Nile crocodiles and the everglades now.
Yeah,
that's scary.
So they,
they,
they issue to kill on order for these Nile crocodiles.
As far as they know,
they don't have a breeding population,
but there definitely have been spotted in the everglades,
which is fucking real problem assholes,
Florida,
the fucking cock of the country that are,
that place is crazy.
Phil would nutty white people who are on bath salts and the fucking throwing
snakes out their car window when they're driving down the street.
Then they're assholes.
Florida is filled with the redneck.
He has redneck assholes on the planet.
It's a lot of fun down there though.
It's on another level from the deep south.
You know,
it's like the deep south.
That's like the Mexico of the deep south.
That's what Florida's like cause it's like you go below the deep,
deep south is all class.
He and shit.
You can go to Tennessee and be a gentleman,
have a bourbon and you know what I'm saying?
But you get down to Florida and shit gets crazy be.
Why?
Because it's the Mexico of the south.
That's what it is.
It's like,
man,
it's barely America.
When you're in Florida,
go do gigs in Miami.
Dude,
you are barely in America.
And I say that in a good way.
Like it is a beautiful energy.
Like they're fun.
Fucking peep on that.
So one of the best places to go if you want to just go and unwind and have a
good time.
I love watching all those,
uh,
you know,
cocaine,
cowboys documentaries about how like basically Miami has just built,
built out of cocaine real and murder.
That's,
I mean literally built.
That's like literally built the city.
Yeah.
That dude,
Billy Corbin.
I met him in uh,
in Florida.
He's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Those documentaries,
God damn good cocaine cowboys won the two Giselda.
Is that what her name was?
Just tell the blonde girl Roselda Zelda.
Ooh.
She was scary.
Did you ever see the gun?
Don't second cocaine cowboys where it's dude was
dude was banging her was like making it happen.
The Oakland guy was like,
shit,
Billy's man,
it's hilarious.
He was just,
he stroked out there to get his little stick way at every time he got to jail.
And then how about the fact she got out?
That should be by action.
You're going to get at do some you got to get at do some salute,
man.
He for him.
Fuck yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is a strong mills.
You couldn't take a pill and just go in where he had to get that shit up for
grizzled.
Yeah.
That is a strong move.
Are we sure that it was before there was Viagara when was fired?
I was like in the eighties man.
It was,
it was it the eighties hmm.
I'm pretty sure this was in the eighties early nineties at demos.
When did they invent Viagara?
Brian Know Brian at his home.
The weather was [inaudible] 78 degrees.
Those core,
those commercials are always so lame.
It's always like a couple with gray hair and they're holding hands and they look
at each other and they come close and you know the cuddle,
you know it's,
it's never a dude with a maniacal look on his face and a boner that's five hours
old will not die and he's sweating and his heart,
it's fucking Liba Navis
chest.
It's never that.
I'm always curious about the one that says it lasts for three days and you can
just like kind of call upon it when you want.
Jeannie,
you keep for three days.
I'm on that shit right now and it sucks it really the three day things not that
good like it.
All right.
Explain to me how that works,
what you can just summon a boner while you were on it.
I noticed like the first day it's like just intense,
like everything that happens close to your Dick,
it just makes a boner immediately.
Like today it's more like if I start touching it or if something,
if Jamie starts like kissing it with is pretty lips,
then it would definitely like shoot right back up.
But it's not as sensitive to the point where I'm like walking around like
Goddammit,
I have a boner right now where the first day he is third day.
It's just kind of like you have to try a little harder.
But when it's ready,
if you take invite Viagra or Cialis or which,
which one of them was,
this was black power,
which is,
oh,
it's probably see the Alice,
but it's a bigger pill so it's more Cialis than a normal pill.
So it's like five days worth of Seattle.
Oh my God.
Why are you taking all of that?
Because I have,
but I don't you
be a better idea.
Don't think it'd be better.
I did just take like half a pill.
Have you ever thought about taking half a pill?
No.
Cause I do you think are you going to die?
Oh,
where are your heart's going to fucking give out?
I think boner pills at a certain level or unhealthy.
Well,
it's weight loss problems other places.
Most of the time
it's like it's hard to borrow it temporarily,
but the interest rates get higher the longer you hold onto it.
Check Danielson's Ferris,
so he says
biological lunch,
there's no bug free book,
biological,
free lunch.
When you take something and it has a very positive reaction and also probably
has some side effects that you're not really aware of that are equally powerful.
Yeah,
ripping pussy apart.
[inaudible] another thing it does,
it really helps.
It's not coming at all.
That's like if you sometimes don't even come and you're just like,
all right,
I just fucking made that chick have like the best sex and the whole entire
world.
I know many people across the country or a barfing right now I'm just thinking
of you having sex with anyone and you're talking about Taryn pussy apart and put
a quilt quilt done.
After that they hurt your brain or
brain already heard which one is,
that's crazy talk.
No,
it's cool.
You should probably have less.
I think there's,
there's a certain dangerous with it but you know that's one thing that is weird.
Apparently it didn't enhance his athletic performance.
It's banned in the Olympics
cause it's three cycles.
Your,
your blood positive
doctor Brian,
how would you a scientifically described the effects of it moves the blood she's
down around or your place.
Yeah,
but apparently enhances endurance.
I like how the pill was called the black power black power.
It's a,
it's a white guy.
Fucking a black chick on the cover.
Okay.
Right.
Got It.
Cause I was like damn,
he's making that grow happy.
Yeah.
Skinny white guy is only get white girlfriend or only get black girlfriends.
You know those dudes,
the white dudes are only Jewish guy.
Tell a lot.
We take those things man.
I got,
you know,
with the heart stuff.
But I remember,
I remember when I got out of hospital,
a really important thing to me was the doctor said you can't have sex so you
could walk a flight of stairs.
Wow.
And I would look at the stairs like every day and be like,
I'm gonna try it.
Three steps.
And I'd come back down to,
we bought a week and a half.
Now when they date,
they give you open heart surgery or they have them open up your chest bone?
Yes sir.
What does that like,
how long does it take before that heals up?
Um,
do you feel it now,
like when you touch it,
does it bother you?
Sometimes I feel the wire through the skin.
Yeah.
Cause they wire it shut.
You know what I mean?
There's a little wire in and when I get x ray you see like,
it looks like a little Barb wire thing wrapped around the sternum.
Does that go off when you go through the metal detectors?
Man,
they'd have,
they have to have it once or twice in my life since this happened.
I believed that,
that it's that set it off.
But it's like when they're on super high,
like if they're set high,
I think I've got,
I've gone through those,
you know the full body,
they never say a word.
They never asked me about anything.
I don't even know if they see the full body is a radio wave thing and what it's
looking for is external objects.
Right.
Looking for shit that you might have in your pocket and like shanks,
you know sometimes like those lines,
those make it go off if it,
if it's set re you know,
ridiculously high.
Wow.
Like I've had guys go like what is that?
And I'd be like,
I won.
I didn't wear a necklace to the,
I was like you must be getting either the wire or my valve.
Wow.
Right through the skin.
How fucked up is that?
We have to test people from metal,
make sure they're not bring anything hard on them.
Does it feel foreign?
Like sometimes there's like vibrate during certain things.
Like if you're like on a roller coaster,
do you feel like I just certain foreign object inside of you?
No,
no,
no.
It's all the,
you know,
the crazy part is like acoustics of rooms.
Sometimes if I'm sitting in the right spot,
it's so loud.
It's ridiculous because it's like tick,
tick,
tick.
Yeah.
Like people,
I'll be like,
what the hell?
You know,
if I'm in the right spot in the right room,
that is why,
because 90% of the time for me,
it's white noise.
You know,
I to just kind of,
I don't hear that anymore.
I want to,
I can hear it click his life.
Yeah.
Oddly enough is it,
you know,
it's,
it's a clock.
To me it's like,
all right,
that's,
that's each one of those is the second I was thinking about it the other day,
I was just talking to somebody about like,
you know,
when you really figured out what,
how many days we live?
Maybe thirty five thousand forty thousand days.
Is that a lot?
365 days a year.
So ten seven hundred 3000 so you know,
23,000 if you live 60 years,
70 years,
call it 70 70 times 365
sounds like we were all math retards.
It's a lot of time and somewhere in that neighborhood.
Right?
I'm sure a lot of days 40 let's call it 50,000 days.
Your life is right.
Does that sound like a lot doesn't to me?
No.
It doesn't sound,
I equate it to dollars,
man.
I could spend that now.
I go to here right now I spent $50,000.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I hear you.
I wouldn't want to,
that would suck,
you know?
But unless you're a gambling man,
you know,
or just an ass.
Yeah.
I think we like to think that the shit is going to last forever,
but clearly it's not.
Yeah,
it's really short,
man.
That's the one thing that whole thing really made me realize when I was laying
on the thing going in thinking I was,
I was literacy mainly thinking I was,
I wasn't coming out of it.
I was like,
I'm dying.
Do you know the whole,
for me,
I didn't see visions of flashing before my eyes.
It was just the whole,
I think I might even said it on the show before.
It was the summation of like,
that's how long it was.
Right.
That was a blink of a fucking I from birth till now.
Which is,
wow.
And that was,
you know,
and that's really my biggest lesson out of it.
And now I've got a clock ticking.
I'm the,
I'm the crocodile from Peter Pan,
you know?
Well,
when you go through anything that really makes you think that it could be over
there,
makes you reassess the whole picture.
Sometimes we just get real used to everything used to be and you know,
I build to go to the supermarket and get food.
You get used to being able to get up in the morning and walk,
you know,
you get used to all being alive.
Being alive.
Yeah.
Just the,
just being conscious.
I mean,
the world is a strange,
strange fuck place manner,
which is so used to it.
We don't even think about a stranger does.
Every once in a while I'll sit back and just think about the actual breath I'm
going to take.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
What that,
what we just and what you took in,
what your body took out of it,
what you're pushing out.
You know what I mean?
That one simple thing is,
is,
is high science and it's invisible completely.
You need it and it's invisible.
You don't even know where it is.
It'd be in a room,
there's none of it in there.
And they walk in there and God.
Whoa.
What,
what led you to,
to,
to the Muslim religion as opposed to like Christian with a family that,
um,
was,
was Muslim.
They never once talked to me about or anything.
I found some literature that I've read and listened to a tape or two and at the
F my fundamental understanding of it is it's actually all,
it's all three of the Judeo Christianity,
you know,
it's that whole,
it's a summation of all three is it?
Yeah.
What are the,
what are the three,
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam.
It goes through all those so called profits and all that.
And to be honest,
it's like all those,
you know,
the more the older I get,
the more I see.
Those are stories I still,
like I said,
believe in the creator.
I believe,
see Islam for me just brought me like,
oh,
this is all connected.
And it was like very much about peace in a time in my life when I needed that.
And,
um,
but like I said,
like I,
I have not part of any mosque.
I'm not part of any and I haven't even,
I don't even practice like that.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
for me,
it's like personal.
Again,
if it wasn't me and you having this discussion,
it's like,
man,
it's not,
it's not even important,
right?
It's my thing.
Whatever,
yours is yours.
Right.
Cause if I was a real Muslim,
like hardcore,
everybody,
it's praise Odin,
I'd be all offense.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that would be a great use of it.
And it's just,
and it's so silly because it's,
it's like,
come on,
we're,
that's kind of the point,
you know what I mean?
And,
and I,
that's when religion for me gets narrow minded and just,
I can't,
I can't follow that path.
So what you say is that you benefit from it,
you felt you find benefit from the knowledge I've taken from it and I don't,
I'll never,
I mean you could say I'm Christian and Islam and Muslim because I've practiced
both in my life.
You were talking earlier about Catholicism.
I have,
I was raised like in going to catechism school and all that and learning the
lessons.
And then at 14 I had the,
uh,
what they call it,
confirmation,
which was you go before the bishop and you basically do this thing and you can,
you're,
it's like you're sort of Bar Mitzvah of a Christian and Annette,
that symbolic way.
We didn't get any checks or big parties.
Um,
you know,
it wasn't a big of like that.
It was just kind of,
you go there and you're a man now and you get the Holy Spirit is supposed to
come down in you.
And I was buying in at that age,
you know,
I mean I bought in,
I was going to it all and I remember sitting there and the church and the guy
anoints you with the thing and you say the words and I'm walking back and I sit
down in my pew and I'm like,
okay,
it's going to have another,
kids are kind of act,
act not.
It wasn't like,
ah,
this happened to me.
Book kids were like happy in the Aa and I just didn't feel it goddamn thing.
And for me it wasn't that I thought religion was bullshit.
Like how you turned.
That was for me it was like,
Oh man,
there's something wrong with me.
Oh for a long time.
You know what I mean?
And then like I said,
I found this other thing that Kinda was accepted me on my own,
on my own terms.
I,
nobody introduced me to Islam personally.
Nobody said this is what you should think or believe or here's something for you
to read.
This stuff fell into my lap and I was like,
like I said,
I follow signs and so that got me through a very,
I believe like that philosophy and the way it took my mind are one of the
reasons I'm still alive today.
I think there's some great,
yeah,
lessons and a lot of organized religion and some great lessons and in both the
Bible and the Koran and the tour,
this is a great lessons in there.
The problem is they're old as fuck and they need to be updated like they need.
There's not,
it's not a bad thing to have something like a Bible,
but it's a bad thing to have some old shit that nobody truly understands and not
have some just guidelines of how to live life and be a happy,
healthy person and don't,
you know,
don't necessarily say that they came
from anywhere.
You don't know where the fuck they can't from.
But these are things that people have accumulated and we figured out in time
what's up.
I got a song if you got a song about this religion.
Oh,
okay,
beautiful.
Let's do it.
Isn't my religion.
Okay.
Friday,
it's almost like we set this up.
Well,
that's why I had to grab the guitar.
Powerful.
Everlast that's my religion.
This call Friday the 13th okay.
Oh,
thanks man.
Down with red lights.
Shine wants to junk is foul down the bed.
The Sun rass run out of smashes him.
The drugs they sound clear from over here.
Todd is throw some money on table.
Go from last night's loving God so loved the hall.
Got My heart of with known to man
fucking things up.
I do the very best that I can.
I'll come.
Y'All got crazy.
We're smiling.
The money and the eye last crazy.
Nobody wants to go to heaven.
Holdup Hoda.
Hoda.
I got mad as dragon.
Hold up.
What got you distracted?
I'm ready to call you out on taking my head.
I'll listen to that if you were on the phone.
My bad.
No,
don't let it distract me.
You're fine.
I was worried it was an important call.
No,
I don't turn my phone never calls me during the blog.
I don't judge.
I'm just saying I lost my fucking whole train of thought.
So we're going to do this again from the top.
Okay.
All right.
I wound up on that song.
Sorry.
I get a voicemail.
I got nervous.
I don't blame you.
I,
I live in fear of the,
of course I don't want just like God.
I couldn't even let go of it in my brain.
I had to stop,
start over.
They see everything's fine.
Real relax.
Shai wants to,
John's foul down the bed and wants to sound rises when out of spasms in the
drugs,
this out to clear middle here,
it's hot as an oven.
Push come to shove and throw some money on the table.
Cover last time stuff and got the solar.
The whole got the heart of a lone man
fucking thing.
So,
but the best that I can,
just lack of a horse to the wilder.
The walnuts drank it hill and no one should know the scared little,
but I'm really one hell of man.
And now I'm a junkie.
Fall in love.
It's a Java stranger's hair
ever.
Things love up in the heavens.
But here you must atone for your sams for charging one lost stock badge,
high bleed again,
still out seeing the singer sewing machine can be gay cow.
So we get nice
clean and with that scared to have knowledge.
You Bow,
you got the mind of a leper,
the love and saw Chuck Kane
and it's not breaking down.
And that's true.
Leo Survival.
Cleveland sacrificial brand new raffle Gurus,
government issue.
Hoffler stone got a knob that's about taking
the fucking posting up phones with us going sweet.
My name
cause the owl going around stupid.
The owl got lazy.
It was bowel and Barney in the idolizing.
Crazy.
I didn't want to go to heaven,
but everyone's afraid to die.
God is real.
But religions out.
Just one
boss said lower body.
Somebody's got to smoke.
It said one big you.
Aw Man.
That's your really,
it was horrible.
No,
that was great.
It's horrible.
No.
So it was a real moment,
man.
No,
I let my mind get away from me on that one.
Listen,
I shouldn't have answered the phone.
I was going to be polite and leave the room.
You got to do it,
that would be more distraction.
Okay.
All right.
Let's do a,
all right.
We'll do this.
Lawrence pound.
Sam,
not long ago,
last Slu,
Lazo Stern and justice to people were behaving like they are good.
A little ball wasn't misled by none little ball.
This is what he's saying.
Me and you,
God,
we're going to make some cash.
Rabid new foods.
Then Megan a dash,
the deer.
The Jab,
money came.
Ease wrap,
boom.
Had a disease.
He wrapping up.
Amnon was sister and a brother,
Chad rapper man was DT on the cover.
The cap grant is on stopping Dagney.
Radicchio keep still bold.
There's no need for static.
Almost a man as a gay Muslim.
Linda didn't know little ball.
A strap pulled out his card,
so why you hit me?
Bill headed straight for the cow.
Kidney cap gets scared.
His styles to finger do is if I pull this trigger.
So good Dass Dick van around black cow radios in with another lady.
Cow Ran by treaty,
resolved since the chapel.
The head shot back,
but he messed up.
Lou rounded from Max big tits and he decided he'd hit full the subway station,
but she was coming.
So when may left,
he was right on.
Speed was out of breath,
knocked the no man down.
Swelly killed him the meters.
Lou Duane abandoned building ran upstairs to,
that's how I flow Wooten up the door.
And guess what it saw Dave,
the dope fiend shooting dope.
Don't know the meaning of water.
No soup.
He said,
I need,
let's hurry.
Young duping brought back the spank and shy went outside.
There was Casal Luke's who dipped to car wasn't stolen.
Brock,
do you need three?
Crashed into extreme.
He University Scape [inaudible] Senate Ratatat tatted,
no cat scan went out of Berlin,
but it's still has static.
Ran a brain and then it blew down your own man.
[inaudible]
Hanson come through later,
told the cops back off or hunting his dead deep in his heart.
He knew it was wrong,
so it let to let it go and he starts to move on.
Sirens sounded,
seem to sit down and found out the little ball got surrounded.
The dropped his gun.
So when this is where it got to in this story,
he was only 19 and man man's dream,
I hope pantsuit kid is still hear him scream the same funders don't you Dan lab.
Just another case about the round bat straight and now who your soul gets cas.
Good night show.
Oh yeah.
That was beautiful.
That reminded me of the Trayvon Martin case.
Man.
There's a lot of that in there.
What's was going on with that didn't have just in the trial is about to start
again.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on with that.
I think it's,
it's heated up.
It's in the news all the time.
It's,
it's fascinating the case man.
People are in real trouble for manipulating the news.
The way they,
uh,
they portrayed it.
A lot of people were under the impression that that was like a little kid.
There was like really small and those were like really old pictures of him.
You know,
he's a much larger kid and they,
he beat the fuck out of that guy before the guy shot him,
he had blood all over his head.
His nose is punched in.
There's a lot of weird shit as to whether or not,
you know he was a victim or he was an asshole and that he shouldn't have been
doing in the first place.
It's good.
It's a very racially divisive issue,
you know?
It's really fucked up issue.
He's alive though.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
You could take a punch in the nose.
You can apologize for that.
You can.
You know what I mean?
Well,
you know what man,
if he thought that dude was going to kill it right or wrong and I'm outside,
I'm just saying like one dude's alive,
one dude's dead and one dude was following another dude when he have been.
I had,
apparently that's not true.
Apparently a,
that was something that was also reported.
That wasn't true.
He didn't,
they didn't follow that kid.
Apparently they told him to stop and he got in his car and the kid was looking
for him.
But who the fuck knows?
You know when,
when something like that happens?
I never heard that,
but I don't.
I'm in a bunch.
Bunch of different versions of something.
World problems.
Yeah.
None of them are from,
but that song reminded me of that a lot.
You know?
Slick Rick Song.
Children's story.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
that's right.
Once upon a time.
How long ago was Amazon guys?
All this learning and jobs.
That's the,
you know Andy?
Wow.
It's so different.
I didn't even recognize it.
That's the front of my brain to shake off that because I hate when I screw up
or,
or just getting a little something.
Yeah,
I know.
I can have the best set ever,
but I fuck up one joke and that shit will haunt me for days.
That's why I had to do another one right away.
I sit here looking at you like,
wow,
that was fucking awesome.
Don't worry about it,
man.
It doesn't Peter.
People don't think that it comes out right every time people know that's,
that's,
that's the beauty of the does.
I'm worried about people.
Joe Rogan people have been nothing but good to me.
I'm just saying,
me personally,
personally,
right
there.
Nobody else understand that.
Accept you right now.
You know,
other people like it's no big deal,
man.
It's no big deal.
Still all awesome.
That's a beautiful song,
man.
That religion songs,
beautiful song.
A lot of people that's going to be the anthem.
It's just me saying like I said,
what if God is real?
And then legends all just a big lie,
you know?
Well,
you know,
that's Kinda how I look at it.
Like God might be real man.
You know what I mean?
I kind of feel like it is whatever it is.
I think it's,
it's beneficial or not going to be pleased with them.
Motherfuckers murdering each other over the rules.
I think it's beneficial.
There's one rule that we all,
we all know it,
right?
Do one to others.
That's the rule that it really is.
That's the only rule.
I think it's beneficial to be humbled by religion actually is the last line in
that song.
Somebody needs to spark it and being fired.
That's a real religion.
Everything he says,
it's not a religion has never taken a pot cooking,
gotten on an airplane.
That's a real religion.
That's real.
It's real.
It's,
it's,
it's humbling and makes you think about your childhood.
It makes you think about love and happiness.
It makes you think about honesty and friendship and makes you think about
creativity.
That's real man.
That's theirs,
that's connecting you with a spirit of nature.
It made you paranoid.
Yes,
it made you feel weird,
made you have all these crazy thoughts cause it's connecting you to the spirit
of nature,
the mother Earth Gaia in a little baby dose of a plant love.
And that baby dose of plant love just sparks every cannabinoid receptor in your
fucking monkey brain.
And you start seeing shit in a way that you're not going to see without the weed
like it or not.
But if you're a man of your own creation,
absolutely you have gotten you where you got because of hard work and
dedication.
So true,
so true.
But you know what?
You will have an experience with that.
Marijuana spirit gets into your bloodstream.
It gets in your system and gives you a little dance and you can accept
the fact that you were tuned into some other form of intelligence.
You could accept the fact that there's something about this thing that's making
ideas explode inside of your brain and never been there before.
Or you can just fucking keep drinking coffee,
go to work and just believe in stupid shit.
Been working right.
Oh it is.
Double Rock did the this is there a better voice voice one.
The silver one is better
so it gives you a very specific sound.
Oh,
here's this one.
Here's this one compressed.
Oh,
okay.
Pretty low compression.
No Mike Better.
It'll make for a better audio on this thing and you could call me up and do
dirty talk to me and I wouldn't even know it was.
Yeah,
I'd get scared.
That's not what I want to hear.
Kettlebell workouts.
I'm doing battle ropes today,
brother.
Today's battle rope day.
What do you got now?
Man,
we'll do another one.
I can shake off that bullshit.
Oh you son of a bit
still still.
It's still,
no,
it's gone.
I apologize with all my heart.
I did not think that that was kind of distract you dude.
I've done it to every interview ever cause I won't turn off my phone,
God forbid in case on it.
And it wasn't a judgment.
It was just like I just couldn't,
I had the cords in my hand,
started playing another song and then lyrics from another song.
It's like some weird,
I've never written anything down.
So it's like if a,
if a picture gets cross referenced it,
I,
I'm fucked.
That is such a fascinating way to do your music.
I know Jay Dee Dee,
Jay z does his raps that way too.
I think that's really fascinating.
I mean for me it's,
again I think we discussed it but it's like it started as like a wrap thing.
Having a hall right here,
I don't need it.
Well you probably should,
you know,
I mean there's probably some benefit to having it all right there.
You know,
be able to pull out at anytime you want instead of relying on pieces of paper
and you record it all.
And like I said,
when I open my eyes and saw something and,
and then your brains,
you know,
automatically is asking questions.
So,
you know what I mean?
It's not even,
it's just like,
that's not even like fuck Joe.
It's like what's going on?
Something bad happening and that's enough that the songs gone.
It's like,
I think it's cool for people to just get my fucking eyes closed is what I should
did.
That's what I,
that's why I closed my eyes a lot during performances cause it's sometimes some
mother fucker will turn around and like do his Facebook photo,
shoot a Selfie with me in the background,
like in the middle of a con like fuck,
come on.
Right.
We used to go to concerts to listen to watch concerts.
Right now they're like watching it through their phone for their youtube post.
Yeah.
They're looking at their life through a little four inch window instead of
living.
If it's distracting and calming shows.
You see a lot of that.
A lot of people holding their phones up.
You know,
on one hand it's nice you want to take a picture of me.
But on the other hand it's kind of weird.
It's,
it's what's called weakness.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] name was Lucy Cadillac,
this monkey.
So now
I got a weakness
top down afternoon.
She made me cry,
limit deep.
And Matt asked,
grandma died when she was five and she didn't know.
She seen
you will hurt deep in my bones.
I got a weakness out of the sitting on the edge.
She's saying I slept with gangsters,
thugs,
smuggler,
Congress smelling govern,
missing golden man.
But this weakness is,
it's Matt
starts to
sell map.
Yes.
My scan and
I got a weakness.
You
know
I
got a weakness.
I have beaver,
I got
edge.
Just Wayne.
Yeah.
And you paint with a dark brush.
Don't,
don't.
Yeah.
Almost always.
I mean there's happiness in it,
but you pay with,
oh yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Yeah.
There's the bad.
This whole little bit.
All the interesting people do that.
Unfortunately.
I hate giving people the impression that you have to make sad music though.
Cause I mean I,
it's just not what I do.
When you are happy music,
not,
I can't write that song,
jump around.
You know what I mean?
You know,
that's just a whole different different time to write for you.
Do you hear like that old stuff like the,
the,
the rap stuff and go like,
wow,
that's like a different time.
Yeah.
My voice and I know I'm just a baby.
I haven't even had,
I didn't even find my voice until like the third house of Payne record.
It's weird isn't it?
When you look back on all the shit that you've done and it took me like three
albums to find my singing voice.
You know what I mean?
Like Whitey Ford isn't,
when I find a singing,
it's good work,
but it's not my best.
Like thank God nobody talked you out of putting out that record.
Tell that story.
Cause Tom,
hey,
they tried.
That is so frustrating to me because it's always the case where people just,
for whatever reason,
they,
they don't ever want to accept that a dude.
Like you could do more than one different kind of thing,
you know?
Yeah.
I hear that man.
Um,
I just,
again,
I follow the signs.
I just Kinda of go back.
I got,
I got to the point in house pain where I felt like I was showing up for the
checks and that made me feel rather core link.
It must be hard to do things with a bunch of dudes,
even if you love him too,
even if you love him.
Just to throw one.
Writing songs with a bunch of other dudes seems like a nightmare.
Well,
musically I was doing more than my share of the work,
so I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Again,
it just became not fun.
That's really what it was.
It just do.
It became a point where,
and luckily I'm spoiled rotten enough in my life that isn't,
it wasn't fun.
I wasn't doing it.
Yeah.
And I didn't care.
You know.
And the thing was I wasn't Uber rich when I quit house of pain.
I was,
I hadn't,
I had a few bucks,
but like it was going to be like,
what's next?
Like in life,
what's the next day is I didn't know if I was going to make another record at
all.
You know,
a friend called to come to New York,
fuck record deals.
Fuck labels,
just getting a studio and smoke some dope.
See what happens.
He heard me playing guitar in his living room one night and we got record that
and this turns into that and what it's like is this and then you know,
still I don't,
none of it is like was sup like mapped out in some superior plan.
We didn't have,
you know,
it was all going by your install on the best shit the Hams is by accident.
Of course.
Yeah.
There was a,
there's a very few songs that are guaranteed to give me goosebumps.
But that song that you did with Carlos Santana,
the key,
turn your lights on.
You want to eat?
Fuck yeah.
That's one of my all time favorite songs,
dude,
that song.
But before you even pick up a guitar,
there's some about that song where you know,
when a dude saying something where there's a,
there's an authentic pain being expressed as an authentic emotion.
Every word is like every word is qualified.
You know what I mean by an experience.
And there's a,
there's something that comes out of that and that saw everything from Carlos
Santana's mother fucking guitar that 60 years of,
you know,
bullshit that guy's gone through in his life,
60 plus years to all the shit you were going through when you wrote those,
those lyrics and the way you were singing him.
It was,
that's a,
that's a fucking crispy song,
man.
That song.
Whoo,
that's,
it's crispy.
Like you hear that song and just whoo.
We get those goosebumps.
Selena meant to be things.
You know what I mean?
Cause I definitely,
I had done that.
We had discussed this in detail.
I'd finished or the house or the Whitey Ford record and got out of surgery and
was being leaving a house and got fucked over.
Yeah.
A lot of things happen at the same time.
We're account and fuck me in in the hospital because cause the account,
fuck me,
I canceled my insurance cause I didn't have insurance.
I had a hospital bill at like 400 grand.
I went from overnight being like,
like I said,
a few bucks.
You know what I mean?
I had like cash,
maybe like half a milli or something.
You know you need people right now,
but wait a minute,
this is what the fuck was depressed.
He had half a million dollars one day the day before.
Oh.
Then the next day I owed the government like fucking after they took all the
bread,
like I still owed like the government in hospitals,
like half a million.
So you went a million dollar swing in like a day,
let's call it a week.
Oh my God.
You hear in the news about getting screwed.
But then I had this song and somebody says Santana's looking for a song and sent
it and we talked about the rest man.
But it was the first song he cut for that album.
He called it the centerpiece of his wreck.
I'm proud of that.
Give me a call,
man.
I ain't heard from you in like 15 years.
Carlos.
Carlos Santana does not listen to his podcast and somebody that knows him desert
busy being 1500 times
or by the time everybody listens to that old Carlos Santana,
he was speaking to this.
I found a rock on the beach yesterday.
I was with my kids and we found this rock and how there's holes in it.
And I said,
is I like from space?
Like is that an asteroid or a media right or something like that.
Like what is this?
And so I put on Twitter,
I said,
does anybody know any geology people out there?
Know what this is Joe Perry from Aero Smith because the first person to respond
and he says it's,
it's a c,
it's like a type of sea rock.
And uh,
it's a,
it's come from the holes come from water erosion.
I was like,
God damn re the real joke.
And he's the first person,
the first person that responds,
I'll add Twitter.
That's where this t game and tag is nuts.
Joe Perry is a cool motherfucker.
I've,
I've had conversations with them.
Carol Smith,
dude,
one of the bads guitars of all time.
Maybe Joe Joe Perry's baddest lick of all time.
So many of them too.
Not just that one.
I mean,
that's old school Aerosmith.
That's worldwide,
that's darkest corner of Africa bar.
You put that on somebody in that bars and be like Aerosmith.
Oh yeah.
I grew up in Boston,
so Aerosmith has royalty there.
Boston royalty.
They came from Boston,
you know.
Oh that early shit,
you know,
walk this way.
It was tremendous,
tremendous fuel those guys had behind them.
But then eventually it became ballads and he's not only,
but the shocking thing is not that he follows you.
To me,
it's that he's a goddamn gem.
Ologist or whatever.
Well I think he's a part of that whole rock for science thing.
Is that what it's called?
What is it?
Hold on,
let me find out if that's true.
There's something going on,
Brock.
The science,
some,
uh,
maybe this will be a,
somebody can hold up to,
I dunno.
There's something going on.
Rockets.
I Dunno.
I think there's a,
I shouldn't have said that because I don't know the information.
See if you can Google that.
Anybody.
Brian,
see if you could pull up,
cause it's going to take too much,
too much look.
But I think there's a,
the Rock Stars of science.
Maybe that's it.
Yeah.
Rock Stars of Science.
And they're,
what they're trying to do is get kids to be excited about science.
So you've got people like they're following Joe Perry
following rock stars.
So many junior high and elementary school
kicked are falling.
Any rock stars nowadays,
right?
They're all like
little Wayne would be,
you know,
on that.
And you might get them kids deeper little Wayne right now.
Joe Perry's just got,
you know me and you going like,
Damn.
Yeah,
it's Joe Perry.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of people in here and then a bunch of science people.
This is interesting.
So it's actually a show.
What is that?
It's not rock stars and science.
What was Andy do frame in,
in,
in that movie he liked to shape the rocks.
And what did they call that tall?
It is,
I don't know.
It didn't sound like Jamal and just as someone who,
uh,
like his studies rocks,
right?
Just all rock geologists though.
That's geologists,
gem ologists like someone to study jams.
Those Jews in the diamond business,
that movie,
the Shawshank Redemption,
they're moving,
they called him something in that,
that diamonds are like very pretty.
There's no mistaking that,
but man,
what an amazing job they've done in making diamonds like this.
A valuable commodity.
Storing them in a warehouse and releasing them.
One that you keep in the prices elevated.
That's a meme,
right?
Their diamonds are very pretty
well,
they are Brian.
Okay.
That's why people are willing to pay money for him,
but it's fashioned.
Keeps so many Australian market.
Yeah,
it's brilliant.
The way they're done is brilliant.
You can,
isn't it kind of modeled after the gas industry hasn't of just the work.
I mean,
I take it that's almost the same principle sort of all these countries.
We have so much in reserve,
but yet,
you know what I mean?
It's the cast is necessary.
Diamonds that serves.
There you go.
That's it.
That's much more gangster talk people into buying a shiny rock for no fucking
reason.
It's marginally talks people into it,
but it's like you have to buy it for the woman you love half tablet.
The genius.
She was like,
it's part of society now.
Like that's you're expected to buy a diamond ring for an engagement or wedding
or whatever.
I mean that's expected.
You cast your Dalry he can't be coming home with no rubies.
No,
that's your dowery and it has to be like three months salary.
Yeah.
What's so good fucking assholes.
That's an asshole slogan.
Be honest though.
I wish I had only spent three minutes.
Where were you then?
It's a slogan,
man.
It's like have it your way at Burger King.
You know,
they're just selling shitty cheeseburgers,
you know,
don't,
don't try to make it is,
my wife has an official one engagement ring.
When I flew I flew her to Paris.
Just kinda like,
I decided it was like,
no,
it's time Paris.
Yeah,
I was on tour.
Oh well I flew her like out to Europe.
We hit Amsterdam and few other places,
but I,
my plan was Paris midnight,
Eiffel Tower movie style.
That's bad ass.
But like I knew I had a jewelry guy here at home.
I'm sure you know who he is.
Dana put me onto him.
Okay.
So he was,
he's like,
I got you.
So when you get back.
But I was like,
I gotta do this.
So I went into a little London,
a jewelry store and bought like,
you know,
$500 little sliver diamond ring and you know my wife treasures that just as much
as the other one because that's when I gave her at the thing
I did.
I'm like,
Yo,
like you would have saved me a lot of bread.
Well I think they like both but it's a weird,
this one is special because this one came,
this one is,
no,
that makes this one special.
Right.
It's a weird thing that people are willing to spend so much money on some little
tiny piece of rock.
It doesn't really do anything was that was very strange.
It was coal.
Yeah.
Long time ago.
It was a thing in wired magazine years back where there was a guy who was using
Russian technology and he was creating diamonds and the significant ones like up
to two and three carrots I think.
And they were also making different color ones,
which are really rare,
but they were able to,
I was just going to say I have an old like 20 year old,
like I have a canary yellow diamond pinky ring and it's like,
it was really,
it's really Rick because it's natural,
but nowadays it's like you can get them like,
I mean that's why all these guys have like rainbow fluorescent,
like diamond.
Well that's all fake anyways.
90% of that shit.
Right.
But here's what's fascinating.
I have a great idea for a show,
Joe.
Okay.
It's gotta be somebody that can fight though.
Richard Simmons,
I'm serious.
Like,
yes,
I can do a diamonds,
red carpet.
Fucking somebody on the red carpet at all these advanced and like all these cats
that
wear this ridiculous jewelry.
Primarily wrappers.
A diamond tester.
Oh,
that would be so rude.
That'd be so rude.
No,
you'd be blown.
People's spots.
It got to do it.
It's ridiculous,
man.
There's guys walking around that that got like apartment complexes around their
neck if they're real.
And those dudes,
if they're real,
I got guys that want to get at him.
How rude that is.
Not Very Islam have you sir.
That is not very nice guys.
They weren't sure who they are,
where they are.
This is what's fucked up about the machine that makes the diamonds.
I've talked to several women who said this exact same thing.
They say that those diamonds wouldn't be as valuable to them because they came
from a machine that they want the kind that comes from the ground and I'm like,
even if it's just perfectly exactly,
exactly duplicated.
It is a diamond.
Like the only way you can tell that this diamond and this is,
this is a fact,
like this is not a disputed thing.
The only way you could tell,
because if they tell you like they've taken these diamonds to gem ologists,
people work in the diamond trade,
the DeBeers group,
and they've looked at them and they cannot distinguish these from perfect
diamonds.
Like they can make a perfect diamond.
So it's a real weird thing.
But for women,
that's why we walk will lie to women.
It's a real weird thing.
But for women,
that thing is that the one that's more valuable is the one they want.
They want the one that costs more.
That's what I'm telling you.
It's the actually want it to be worth more.
They want some sort of twisted revenge on the fact that original marriage was
basically an exchange of pop property or a property for wife property to,
you know,
become the daughter property because why property?
What are you giving me?
I think they do it for girls as much as they do it for themselves.
I think they do it to show other girls to have big as bowling ball on their
finger.
Look what he got me.
That's how I got my plus as,
okay,
I'm looking at here.
You got me.
Exactly.
You know,
and want to let you know they rock.
Some mother fucker brought them in a boulder,
you know,
and it's like,
well this is like a little competition.
Like who did better,
you know?
Well,
I mean to the same degree as we all want hot wives.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
We all want a nice car.
You also,
yeah,
but you want to fuck hot wife in it before she's the wife of course.
And then you buy or like an SUV or something to cars I like or not.
I don't like,
I'm comfortable cars.
I like cars that are stupid.
My wife does not like any of my cars.
I like to drive my car,
my Nice,
my fun,
my toy toy car,
that dope Audi spaceship thing.
That's,
sorry.
That's one of the most beautiful cars ever created.
That Audi r eight masterpiece.
A masterpiece.
And like if you were a kid like back in the 1980s and shit and you look back at
the future like what's a car guy looked like in the two thousands that Audi,
is it man,
that's a fucking spaceship.
A four wheel drive spaceship with paddle shifters.
It's fun.
It's a dope car,
man.
You got some,
you got some stuff?
Yeah,
my favorite car.
I've got a Porsche gt three gt three Rs.
This the stupid car.
Nobody should be able to buy that.
You shouldn't be able to buy something like that and just drive it around.
It's a race car.
It's ridiculous,
but it's,
you're so connected.
You know what?
I'm a really been getting into man though recently really been getting into old
cars.
Like when I look at like there's something to me like I went for a long time.
I didn't dig old cars because of my,
I had a bad experience with a car.
I had belt at a 1970 barracuda built.
Right?
But there's some about like old cars,
like if you get,
get them to run and drive them around,
there's so much more satisfying.
If you could actually get a 1969 Camaro and drive that motherfucker around,
you could actually get it to the point where you could actually drive it,
make sure that it stops when you want it to,
and make sure that blinkers work and all that bullshit.
If you could like get it shipped down to that point,
you're in a,
you're on a goddamn time machine.
You're driving around in a a working piece of art that sounds like fun,
like a giant Dick roaring as it goes down the street.
Everyone old car I want to build,
but I haven't found the right one yet.
Uh,
59 El Camino.
Ooh.
I haven't found the right situation when I've come across them and people would
want too much for him.
It'd be in like Iowa.
Right.
That's a beautiful car.
It's another car.
It's a Goddamn you're,
you're in a different time when you're in that car.
The first El Camino skirts on the back wheels.
Oh yeah,
I'd do it.
Kind of like 1500 is a good year or two.
But interesting year,
you know those,
those cars of the early fifties or the,
the late fifties and early sixties so I didn't,
amazing times man.
Like the old Barracuda,
it doesn't have the best shape in the world,
but man,
it's got a weird shape representative of a strange time,
you know,
in 1968 big ass.
Huge fucking muscle cars.
Yeah.
Slide all over the place with shitty steering.
Like your car.
That car is like intimately connected to every move.
The steering wheel.
Yeah.
And it's bought it or I went and picked up my homie and we were just going
around like the residential neighborhood and I was like,
watch this.
And I was doing like 50 and just dead made a right.
And there's,
you know,
there's a button you press on there like where the shocks fill up with fluid.
So yeah,
it's just,
it's crazy man.
Well let's see.
Got a,
an almost perfect 50,
50 weight balance cause that's a mid engine car.
That means the engine is behind you and your seat.
It was a brilliant piece of engineering,
man.
I was told it's the poor man's Lamborghini.
No,
that's silly.
It's a better car.
It's more,
it's better looking.
Lamborghini looks like you're on coke if you drive it around a Lamborghini.
Honestly,
between you and me,
like I couldn't spend,
when I went to buy that car,
I went to a spot here in Pasadena where there's a bunch of car dealerships,
you know,
high end portion,
all this stuff.
And I went there and I went looking for an eight,
actually just a sedan cause I was,
it's another beautiful,
I've been driving.
Um,
basically Sam series beamers for years.
Like I was,
you know,
and I just wanted to switch it up and I heard that was the same
or similar and then the class and I was a,
so I went and saw it and the salesman told me,
don't you don't,
I told him why I like beamers and oil.
I've been driving them for so long and he was like,
you don't want this car once he,
I was like,
that's exactly what I said to him.
what do you mean?
He's like,
Nah,
this is just saying,
he's like,
this is a great fucking car.
And then I realized,
I think he knows who I am and he's like,
ah,
you know,
you don't want this car.
It was like,
and I'm waiting,
I'm waiting for the pitch.
Like,
okay,
what car do I want then and it,
and it doesn't come.
And he's like,
Nah,
this is just this.
I was like,
well,
what are we?
I was like,
all right,
well cool.
I'm going to go next door and look at it.
Another car,
you know?
And it was like,
there was a Bentley dealership right there.
And I went in there and saw that Bentley coupe and it was like this thing,
it was $250,000.
It's like,
I feel like a jerk off in this car.
Right?
I mean like driving,
it's just,
I'd feel like an extreme jerk.
And I went into the Jag and they'll,
new jag wasn't out yet.
Like I might at that Jag would have been out,
I might have bought,
I might've got that just because I was like,
well,
you know,
and I was just in one of the car that day.
I had a truck,
I got to think I've got to have a car in a truck.
That's my thing.
You know,
there was sometimes more than that,
but I got to have a car in a truck.
So we'll first world problems,
first world problems.
Right.
So then I,
you know,
I didn't see that.
So I'm walking back to get to my car where I parked,
I have to go back through the Audi showroom and then I see the r eight and the
corner and it's white.
And I go there and looking at them and reading.
The guy in the kid comes over and he's like,
having,
this is bad ass.
I was like,
gas stove.
He starts talking to me about it and I'm,
and I'm like,
just kinda national outlet,
you know,
in my brain saying,
I can't get this fucking car man.
You know,
why are we thinking that?
Just because it was like,
you know when them things like that's a win,
you know this,
it wasn't practical at all.
There was nothing practical about it.
There was no back seat for kids.
There was no,
no.
I was like,
nobody's going for this.
My accountant's not going to go for this today.
They're going to break my balls over it.
But then I'm like,
ah,
it was white.
So it's like,
I hate white cars,
man.
I hate him.
And he goes,
I got a black on black carbon fiber one in the bag.
And he was,
I don't even think he thought I was looking.
He was just like,
you want to see it?
I was like,
sure,
I'll come see it and I see it.
And it's you,
you'd see my car at the time of the day.
Was it?
When you saw like four,
oh that's even right up where the sun is just slowly starting to make its way
across.
This carbon fiber was just popping in and out and I was like,
oh my God,
if you could have
the car looked like a sneaker to me and I'm a sneaker freak.
So I was like,
oh my God,
that looks like it's just something,
it reminded me of an Air Jordan somehow.
That's so hilarious.
And then so I'm like,
Yo,
I was like,
let me take it first payment.
And they were like,
Nah,
we don't do that.
We'll take you for a ride.
And he takes me out for some reason.
This is what they told me they were like,
unless they know that it's basically sold,
like in,
they like,
you know,
looking at you like you're buying this car and I had no inkling yet of buying
the car.
What you should do,
just sit down in the purchase seat,
take a CD out,
put in,
jump around and point to and go.
That's me.
I didn't have to do that.
Just let me throw this out in car and we'd go down and it's back there by the
Rose Bowl where it's all canyon and we get like three blocks from the
dealership.
He pulls over and he gets out and he's like,
get in,
drive the motherfucking car.
Smartest the kid ever did in his lap.
That is a good move.
He was fucking,
the bosses didn't know shit about me or anything and I'm tattooed to the kills
and like I didn't even have jewels.
I would look like kind of like I look,
I can help kind of bummy that.
I didn't even have jewels to be walking around with tools.
Man.
I got my,
I didn't have my jewels on.
You know what I mean?
Maybe it's a good sales move by him to pretend they won't let you take it away
and then get outside of town and get,
I'm going to get gangster cause I know you're a bad mother fucker.
Take these keys man or anyone to tell his boss.
Either one of them like go ahead drive it.
Smartest thing he ever did.
Right.
I pulled it back into the dealership
buying this right now,
this is my car.
All right.
And then I'm like,
all right,
let me,
let me show the Wifi and I'm sure the WAC and he's going to be like,
oh,
what are you doing?
And the kids can't sit in that.
I text her,
I think I'm going to buy this car and just sending a picture of it and I'm
waiting and I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
Was somebody going to come talk sense to me right now not to buy this car?
You know,
I wasn't sure.
Is this a midlife crisis?
I was never really a big sports car guy was a big sign,
like a nice sedan,
like old man kind of thing,
you know?
And then my wife sends back to the first Texas,
you deserve it baby.
I was like,
dude,
I got to buy this color.
That's why I wound up with my toy.
Maybe been one of the most heartwarming podcast we've ever done.
Brian.
That's because of his heart inside your pussy tearing stories.
Besides that,
everything else is not how this,
this functioning.
Uh,
you know,
you can just call upon that whenever you want.
The boner pill works.
Having a card like that is like driving a ride.
You're in a ride every day and you don't even have to abuse the law like this.
People don't understand just turning corners at normal speed.
It's like you're so connected to it.
It's fun and you don't even have to be a nun on the freeway and you get nice is
a lot quicker because you can just dart in between.
There's,
the control is so amazing on those cars.
You know what I mean?
You can do things that I would call other people assholes for.
That's when we made engine four wheel drive car.
That's a crazy car man.
That's brilliant.
Piece of [inaudible] sport mode and put those shock absorbers,
fill him up with the fluid and that car is on rails.
Man.
That's said crazy thing about those old cars too,
is that they do a lot of adjusting for you.
If you fuck up,
like there's traction control that comes in and stability control and antilock
brakes,
like do it.
They do a lot of correcting for you,
like to make it much more safe to drive.
The cars were thinking driving.
But that's the thing that bothers me though.
I love that.
But the thing that bothers me is that you miss out on like,
there's like a feel when you drive in a steering wheel that doesn't have power
steering and you know,
you're,
you're hitting breaks that you,
you feel the brakes lock up.
You know,
it's like you have a more of a connection to a car.
Those old cars,
you know,
it's not good.
It's terrible if you want to be safe.
But as far as like real,
I like the Audi.
I like driving it and driving it fast because every once in a while,
even though it's that smooth and cool and everything,
you're so low,
you feel every bump.
And then also every once in a while you'd do something wild enough to,
it makes you realize you gotta be scared a little bit.
Women,
women will never understand.
And dudes who have never driven cars like that would never understand either.
That's one of those things you talk to people in,
they're like,
I don't give a fuck about cars man.
You say that,
but I don't even understand what you're saying.
Like you either haven't driven one of those fucking things or you don't.
You can't afford it so you don't even want to fuck with it.
Which I understood only ridden in them.
They've never done it.
You know,
they've never drove a car.
Sure.
If somebody just came up to you and said,
do you want this?
You'd be like,
fuck yeah,
and then you drive anything like,
Oh man,
this thing is awesome.
You would get it then.
But this first world problems,
she didn't drive this.
He knew.
He knew the minute I put my foot on that thing and so the corner I was going to
be like,
I'm going,
this is cars going home with me.
If anything is,
I remember a guy came up and was like,
I want to look at this.
I was like,
get away from my car.
I like before the paperwork.
That's funny.
We get away from my car,
man,
that's my car.
He's sitting in it and farting and I wasn't having none of that can't be,
that's a,
that's an impulse buy that you could pull off.
You've got damn Everlast.
But if you're a dude who's living in an apartment and you drive one of those
things,
you're an asshole.
Had a good look.
You gotta be real careful about things like that.
Cause he's just like financing.
It just makes it so tempting.
It's almost doable.
If I just work a couple extra shifts washing,
washing dishes or whatever the fuck I'm going to do and slinging drinks,
I can just maybe get that corvette.
It was 150 and it was still like Ooh yeah,
made me go.
It's real money.
I mean like you know a lambo or isn't and that's like two fifties you know what
I mean?
300 I think it's a way better looking car.
I like the Audi better.
I honestly do it.
It's not what never again,
the reason I started talking with us,
I would never,
I mean one that is about my limit where I would spend on a car.
I wouldn't say it's not understated cause it's a pretty audacious car,
but it's classy.
It's beautiful.
It's like it's designed well.
I'm iron man,
dude.
Come on.
That's what I'm talking about.
Shit,
I'm driving.
Right.
That's the one thing still to like it.
That car is like three years old now.
The body sits.
That's a great thing is this device dot.
I ain't going nowhere right now and but like kids still.
Yeah,
like they,
they just light up when you drive by some kids they're like iron man car.
Yeah.
Some people don't get it.
It's a thing that a,
first of all,
they get upset that you're talking about some shit they could never afford.
Sometimes people get upset about that.
They be these two bridge to talking about buying 150,000 because you fucking
kidding me.
It's the last thing people want to hear.
Oh well but oh well
I'm 43 fucking years old,
man.
I've worked 20 fucking years of my life,
I pay mortgages.
Many of them.
I hear you man.
Some of them don't even belong to family members of mine.
Man.
I can not.
I can by myself.
That's what my wife taught me.
That's you deserve that.
That's beautiful.
You earned it.
Yeah,
go get that.
I'm a self indulgent motherfucker.
Yeah.
I I believe in true of what we do.
I believe it's important to be a little self indulgent debate.
I was told by a good friend when I first like kind of made it like,
and I was stressed about this,
that and the other and like every once in a while go out and buy yourself
something,
whether it's a pair of sneakers or something,
he'd just go out and you'll,
you'll feel bad.
This is a certain amount of management you have to do.
Your impulse was,
but I think it's important to be impulsive on a certain level is important to
just go with your instincts on shit,
whether it's with people or with or with business decisions
or with writing material or writing skills.
For my kids,
man,
I would live to the edge Joe.
I'd live to like a penny in the bank and then,
cause I've check always comes like it's eventually I got a good thing going on
man.
Is jump around,
man,
that thing don't go away,
man.
Check.
Like I could live like a pretty,
I think I've been here so many times and we talked for so many hours.
I don't know what I've said to you or not,
but like I could be that huge debt.
Uh,
w what's the dude who got caught with the hooker and in,
in Hollywood grant,
he grant you Greg.
He had a character in a movie that lived off the money of his dad's song and I
that could be that guy so you can live the rest of my life and not do a fucking
thing.
Wow.
I mean,
so I was that guy until I have kids now.
It's like,
Oh shit,
I got to put some of this away.
So,
but I mean,
I would trick money off Joe,
like money,
money,
walking the bars by a bar.
Not the whole bar,
but you know,
any by the bar for the night.
Like how much did you make tonight?
Three grand.
Everybody's drinking for you.
Here's five,
you know,
stupid shit.
I remember one nine Hollywood fucking,
when I was real young first came back to la with like a big stack of money in my
pocket,
went to this club and this bartender chick was just ignoring the shit out of me.
It was a packed night but I was just like,
I was like,
no,
fuck,
this bitch just really ignored me like five times two I pulled out just a stack
of hundreds and I started crumbling them up,
just throwing a matter of throwing them out and like,
and then she realized there was like $700 on the floor and it came over and the
next thing I know I'm,
I'm,
I'm running the bar.
That's hilarious though that throwing money at her just as long as the number
was high enough folding it up and she was like hitting her with it and she
accepted that because it was a hundred dollar bills,
you can't do that shit with toys.
She got very upset that she was getting something thrown at her and then like
she went and picked it up and was like he'd it and like it was like fucking,
this is,
these are hundred dollar bills.
This sounds like a movie in the 1980s and you would wind up sleeping with her
that night and then she would regret it because you were in a band and you were
in a Boston.
Yeah.
Runs right into throwing hundreds of her face.
I've,
I've bought,
bought a bar before,
but the whole bar around the drinks,
I used to kick everybody.
When I kick anybody out of the comedy store,
I'd buy the whole audience around the tracks.
I S oh,
they still love doing that because the comedy store never had any,
um,
there's no one watches the crowd.
Like if you go to a legitimate comedy club and people start mouth and off,
the security guy will come over and tell him,
look,
you're going to have to leave you disrupting the performance.
The company store,
there's no security.
I used to go there all the time.
The dog on Monday nights.
We used to go there and just get nuts,
but yeah.
Well what is the open,
Mike night is a Sunday.
No,
Sunday and Monday.
Yeah.
There was a night where it was like if you went in there,
you'd see a bunch of shit comics,
but you are guaranteed almost that some large cat.
We'd walk in and do something like,
it was like Monday I was at like a tree.
It was like,
this is like almost 15 yeah,
back there.
I think it's still probably like that.
Murphy might pop in and do a set or you know,
last week I was Mike Tyson.
It's like every week
it's somebody like the week before that we Chapelle and Mike Tyson is actually
doing stand up there.
Yeah.
It just crazy.
You imagine that one of the fucking car story you see Mike Tyson doing was,
I want to see somebody heckle a,
that's what I don't think they're going to ask.
What I want to say.
Are you taking it?
We
did.
You see in the jackasses when they let that butter bean dude punch him.
Oh
man,
that guy's going off.
But I wanted like to talk to him about how badly that fucked him up.
He never been in no,
no.
I don't know me here cause I loved that I'd be,
I'd be listening to that multiple times.
Butter bean tee off on him like,
oh,
like his dick.
Literally that was after he was a movie star.
Yeah.
After he's moved,
we started,
puts a fucking blind fold on.
Let's in there with a bullet.
It's the scenes over and he's like,
is this okay though?
He's crazy.
Those guys are ridiculous.
But that butterbeans shit was,
he just stood in front about her being my bottom have been just chaos him.
Yeah.
There's another one where the,
uh,
one of the party boy guy gets punched by by PR guy recognized it was an MMA
fighter.
Yeah,
I remember that one.
Did he actually like tried to have an MMA fight with a real guy from England and
he fought it.
The shit out of Schick whipped the shit out of him too.
Oh Donna,
I think done.
Done right.
Done.
Fought him right.
Died in the car accident or a man.
Yeah.
Those guys are nuts.
Guys are living on the edge man,
you know?
Yeah.
But we get and dude's punch you in the head like that.
That is no Bueno.
I bet you all them dudes.
I mean it's sad.
Is that Ryan done thing is I wonder if he gave if,
if,
if like in the scheme of the story of life,
if that's the better death or if you would have made it to 90 and been boring
and decrepit or cause they live that life,
you know what I mean?
As much as they get paid to do that shit.
There was a time when they weren't right.
I think one of the first things either Bam,
I think it was Knoxville,
didn't he shoot himself with a 44 magnum,
we put a belt bulletproof vest on and somebody shoot him,
shoot him.
So he,
I think he wound up doing it.
I'm pretty sure like,
and that was for like Rainer nit mag when the Internet wasn't anything.
That's a silly bitch.
So you know those guys live for that charge,
that rush.
Well,
the problem is he killed somebody over them.
It must be nuts.
And why I would think it should be a more explored topic is uh,
uh,
Rodeo clowns.
Those dudes who like fucking stop it levels the chase him.
Like,
like what kind of nut do you have to beat her?
Be that guy.
That's a hard living man.
That's a hard way to pay your bills.
You let it can be about the money.
No,
no,
it can't be about the money.
It's gotta be about the money and the thrill.
The bull.
That's unless,
I mean you're not,
so people were saying about this tornado thing,
you know,
sometimes people,
they say stupid shit when it comes to,
uh,
why do people live in these tornado areas?
They can't fucking leave.
They don't have any money.
You know,
people are born and really pouring and lived there.
Yeah.
They barely get by.
And for the most part,
everyone they know is there.
Like it ain't that easy to just move.
But,
but it costs fucking money,
man.
And a lot of people,
once you get a job when the big one hits here and it's like,
wow,
how could you live there knowing that was going to eventually come.
But my point is,
once you've got a job as a rodeo clown,
that's how you pay your fucking bills.
That's how you pay your fucking bills,
man.
It's hard to jump off that Rodeo clown thing.
Where are you getting,
you know,
1500 a week or whatever the fuck those guys are getting.
And then tried to get a job where you get 400 a week and then you miss that
other 900 bucks.
Absolutely.
In the yard.
You know,
by the way,
that gt three is what done killed himself in,
yeah.
So yeah.
Yeah.
He went around a turn and like missing the exit went straight into the woods.
You know,
he was going ridiculously fast drunk.
Yeah.
That's the part of this amazing.
I wouldn't never,
my one,
that's my,
hey gimme gimme gimme a cab.
Yeah,
I got it.
I got a couple of hundred bucks.
And when you live in going all the way across town,
there was no caps.
He was out in the woods who's out in the woods of Pennsylvania.
Crazy Fox.
If you,
uh,
you really think about it,
it's amazing.
There's not more crashes because alcohol's everywhere and people are driving
everywhere.
It's amazing.
Something like on real sports or something like that where they like went and
like really filmed and checked out a football game and like how fucked up they
are before and after going like that.
The cops don't really do much.
They just let all these people,
like thousands of people leave those football games inebriated driving their
cars.
That's a great point.
I never even thought about that because how many,
what is it,
50,000 what does a football stadiums?
50 to 70,000 so 71% of them are drunk.
Yeah,
my God.
Yeah.
Or concerts.
And those people are,
you usually have drugs on top of that,
like acid football in particular.
We didn't say baseball.
If you go to the dodger stadium,
there's not people fucking in the parking lot.
Fucking raging.
Right.
Barbecuing and having four cases of beer sitting outside their RV.
You know what I mean?
Football.
It's like a fucking hold.
They get there in the morning,
they barbecue and get their fucking shit faced before the first quarter even
starts.
How much of footballs gambling?
A lot.
Write a lot.
A lot of why people love it.
It's gambling.
Got It.
What did it like when people in the Midwest is there like bookies all over the
place?
Is that what it is?
Like secret bookies or they,
they know you,
but there must be,
there's bookies.
I can give you five bucks.
He's right now.
How dare you.
This is a respectable program,
sir.
All right,
let's bookies need to pay the taxes.
That's what I say in my book.
He's do pay their tax.
Why do you a Saint Barts?
Oh,
it's something like that.
That's a lot of those dudes that were,
you know,
they're just starting to allow poker again in the United States Internet poker.
They're doing it in Nevada and the way it works is you have to be in Nevada.
When you,
when you get online they have to do it and actually gamble from Nevada.
But as long as you do it from Nevada,
it's legal,
which is a strange thing,
but you can play poker.
Hundreds of poker sites I hear about or they're just free sites now.
Well they're either free sites or they're illegal sites and they were fine for
why,
how could you be illegal and be like,
you know,
cause I would have heard of are all over the television and stuff like that.
Yeah,
those are the free ones.
Okay.
But some of those guys got trouble for doing illegal shit
too.
There was some famous ones that got in trouble,
but the majority of the people who were involved in it,
when it was making billions of dollars,
they had to flee and they all had to go to like the Canary Islands and Shit and
the Cayman's and yeah,
the,
you know,
uh,
what's that one?
Not believes but a Costa Rica.
Costa Rica is a lot of them in Costa Rica too.
And these poor guys,
they're,
I mean they're essentially,
they got the,
they took their business away with law.
People were spending money and people were gambling and doing what they're
wanting to do with their money.
And these guys were collecting millions.
They're making millions a day.
And then all of a sudden they came around with a new law that said,
you know what pitches we're not,
we're not happy with you guys getting rich that easy.
So you know,
you've,
you've leached the profits.
They essentially stop progress.
They stopped the ability to gamble on the Internet.
Even though it's a sort of a weird form of progress,
it's still progress in a freedom sets.
It allows you to do with your money,
things that were unavailable before,
whether or not you want to gambling to be legal.
I want you to be able to do whatever the fuck you want to do.
I don't want to have any control of your life cause I don't want you to have any
control of her mind.
So as soon as we allow people to come in and say,
you can't gamble on the Internet,
like why do you fucking talking about like,
why?
Why would you tell me what I can do with my 20 bucks?
Why do you give a fuck?
Why is this even a conversation?
If you need to get some taxes out of that sanction gambling,
like the lottery should be sanctioned.
It should be sanctioned.
It should all be taxable.
But that's the point.
I was like,
they needed that.
That's what they're doing now.
They're opening it up.
I'm sure they're getting there.
They're rake of that.
Yeah,
and I'm sure the local casinos probably weren't very happy with it either.
You know the,
the card casinos that were making a lot of money,
having people come in and play poker,
all of a sudden you can be naked playing poker at home.
There's a couple right down here like bell gardens and a few places.
So I'm sure those people must have lost money.
And there's a,
there has to be some reasons why they would limit your freedom to gamble.
But the ultimately crazy thing,
it's just free to login of poker in the last,
let's say eight to 10 years.
It's TV,
TV,
rope people in an amazing,
it's hard.
It's just makes me crazy.
Then it's also TV combined with the the,
that's the new American dream.
That quick,
easy.
Yeah.
Not only buck,
but you're super famous.
Then you win the world series of poker and you're the fucking man.
You know Mike Goldberg just interviewed some dude on the last UFC and he was,
he won $18 million in a poker tournament.
Cheese and you're fighting,
nobody makes that much money in a fight.
I mean maybe Floyd Mayweather does,
but that's about it.
As far as like human beings has an insane amount of money,
$18 million in a fucking poker tournament.
They make real money because people love it.
If you get enough people that love it and they're willing to throw their chips
in,
I mean how many people had to be in that for you to win?
I mean that's very expensive.
People tournament or something.
I think it's an expensive by until,
cause those guys are worth so much money.
They'll do that by end.
Big World series one.
The big one in the bag is like they get up to like 8,000 people now starting
those things.
Right.
You know,
we should not Bruce buffer.
Come on and explain all the w Bruce,
I've been meeting the meeting to get buffer on here.
Anyway.
We'll have him come in here and explain that shit to us.
Cause Bruce Buffer.
It's like a serious poker player.
Oh is that right?
Yeah,
he's legit.
Like he goes to the world series of poker.
He makes the final table like he's legit.
Bruce spot was one tournaments and shit.
He wins.
You know poker is a tricky game at Ari Shaffir he,
he used to make a living doing poker when,
when everything's sucked for him as a comedian.
I remember it like seeing him like on a few shows with Ari Shaffir when,
when things were sucking for him as a comedian,
it was making 30 grand a year playing poker.
Just go into the local casinos winning tournaments because he's smart because
he's a smart dude and he can calculate shit.
He knows,
he knows how to play the game and he's disciplined and it would just make cash
and you've got to be able to keep,
you know,
your,
your face,
you know,
stolen to a certain degree.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's a big deal.
There's a,
there's a something and not giving it away to any kind of psychological
giveaway,
you know?
That's,
that's what,
that's what I like watching,
like who,
how that stuff works.
Yeah.
I wonder if you get to play all the time,
you can figure out the math is fine.
Most people can learn it.
There's that,
that's where the talent really comes in,
is that whole psychological side.
I mean,
knowing math is talented,
but you know,
what I'm getting at?
Is it more artistic part of it and when,
if you play it all the time,
if you get really good at just smelling bullshit,
you know,
I mean,
it's like you get good at everything like you get,
you would think.
Yeah.
You get mean people get better at all the subtle nuances of anything they
attempt,
whether it's standup comedy or playing music or anything.
I would imagine that you interact with people playing the card game for high
stakes for a long period of time.
He probably smell some shit on people when they are full of shit.
It's just smell a something little intangible green light
or not or just kid yourself and blow your fat water.
I mean you would naturally just get a sense of it of like that movie true
romance where Christopher Walkin's talking about the tells of a,
you would think you would at least have more of a no.
What a crinkled Brower like when you know,
cause there's people that say psychologically like if you're lying,
you look a certain way or if you're trying to recall something,
you look a different way.
Like your,
the way your brain works.
Like yeah,
you can figure out some of that stuff legitimately.
And when people know that I don't trust them from then on,
now you know the moves.
Oh you know it's left to right.
You know?
Yeah.
You cheat motherfucker.
Looking up to your left when you know you should be looking down to your right,
whichever one that only works if you're amongst unsuspecting people and you
have,
nobody can have knowledge that you have that you know.
I think people are,
everybody is scared of losing privacy and I agree it shouldn't.
Someone shouldn't be able to access your privacy random,
someone's [inaudible].
You should be able to access your email or see what's in your computer,
but I do believe that eventually it's going to be a good thing for the world to
have no privacy.
It sounds stupid,
but I think that a lot of the problems that we have is that you can get away
with shit.
A lot of the problems that we have with as far as like committing crimes,
doing bad deeds to people is that people can't literally read each other's
minds.
I think that's ultimately where we're going.
I think we're going to be,
there's going to be no line anymore.
I think a lot of people's emotional and problems stuff is not realizing that
everybody's exactly like you.
Yeah.
You think your thing or whatever's wrong with you or whatever you think or that
crazy,
whatever.
Everything that happens to you is only happening to you and you're embarrassed
or you know,
I mean,
there's a lot of things like that that people don't realize every single what he
has experienced on some level insecurity band.
You're talking about a one consciousness almost like single consciousness for
the crazy people,
that's a problem.
Well,
you can eliminate them easier.
You got to,
you got to find them and kill him.
But who's who's willing to make that call from notify them?
You can notify them,
hand them up,
box them up,
but then they get out and it becomes a God Damn Stephen King movie.
Yeah,
well you know it's going somewhere someday is it?
Something's going to happen.
What do you,
if you look at,
I mean you're,
you're a thoughtful guy.
When you look at society and you look at Shit what's going down in Turkey and
the clamp down on the Internet where the government's worried about people being
able to rise and,
and the,
the second amendment debates and all the shit that's going on.
How do you,
how do you see this,
this,
this fucking thing turning out?
When you look at our world?
I don't think a lot of it matters,
man.
You don't think so in a weird,
I just think eventually,
you know what I mean?
Like the lights are gonna go out and for you,
for everybody,
I'm talking about literally like not our lives.
I'm talking about sooner or later,
a lot of this is going to go wrong.
We're going to use it.
I don't know how much fuel,
I mean I'm not an expert,
but it fuels gotta be all the fuels that we use so rapidly right now.
Can't be infinite.
You want to hear something interesting?
I talked to,
uh,
whether scientists,
and uh,
he told me that even if we chopped down every tree in the world,
we'd still have a couple of million years of air.
Do you know that?
There's like,
everybody's worried about like losing all the air.
What are we going to do?
I was like,
you know what I mean?
But the world is far more durable then.
Then we pretend it is.
I'm not talking about the world or the planet
within it,
you know what I mean?
And our use of like,
you know,
I,
I don't,
again,
I just said I'm no expert,
but like fossil fuels cannot be infinite,
no county.
So eventually,
you know what I mean?
It's not gonna if the lights are going to go out and we're all going to be
swamped people,
man,
that's funny because I don't think so.
I think that I would've never figured out how to make you want to know.
Honestly.
That's what I hope I would have never figured out how to make a regular engine
and I'm never going to figure out how to make a fucking electric engine and
shoot my gun and I can,
I can reload bullets for sure.
For sure.
There's some people way smarter than me that are looking at all these problems
and the same sort of genius that allowed people get to the point where we have
flying metal tubes to take you from New York to Paris and five hours you did
Howard saying we're going to have the same kind of shit with,
with everything it would.
People are going to eventually innovate pass where we're at.
I have a full family from that because the nine one day,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think it's going to change,
but I don't,
I don't think lights are going to go out.
They might go out for a little while and then come back on.
I mean at any point in time that could be a series of colossal disasters,
natural disasters,
and we just look at the history of the world that we know about for sure.
There's been some,
at least I think there's four or five extinction events that had been marked
throughout history that we know of right now and pretend that we know everything
that happened over the four point whatever billion years
of the Earth's time at this point is,
you know,
that is a lot of shit.
They don't know.
There's 12,002 Asian aliens.
Again,
are we not,
are we going in to the fact that people been,
you know,
lucky that we made it to this point,
but we could go just bite the dinosaur wet this.
It's really my point.
Fuck yeah,
but that will another society eventually rise up and I believe,
yeah.
Okay,
okay.
Whatever.
But like as far as I'm concerned,
like my,
I got my daily problems.
I don't,
I don't the government and the clamp down in the Internet,
fuck the Internet.
I honestly told,
I've said many,
many times if I could get rid of one thing,
like I think for every great thing to Internet's done it.
There's a thousand slimy,
he's coming fucking awful rotten things about it.
Wow,
that's interesting.
I look at it a completely opposite.
I think for every one.
I mean it changed my house,
you know what I mean?
It did.
I change the trajectory of a whole business that,
you know,
I depended on to,
man,
I think Dan took the carpet enabled on delivery on levels that I never would
have imagined in like 1995 it thievery meaning people illegally downloaded
songs.
Yeah.
Not only that.
Okay.
And then let's just go with the,
you know,
small things like,
back,
you know,
maybe in the 90s if there was a guy who liked fucking pigs,
you know what I mean?
He'd be alone fucking wolf somewhere that,
you know,
would never really act on it or anything.
Now there's probably,
you could probably find a website dedicated to that.
Oh,
this is most certainly if people gather and they fuck pigs,
that's mine.
That's bad for society.
Yeah.
Why is it okay to eat pigs?
But it's not okay to fuck them.
That's what I want to know.
I mean,
I feel like,
I still feel like I love you dude.
Podcast is might be over after that.
I don't feel like,
I don't know if I have any response to that legitimately.
I don't feel like that makes any sense.
I feel like,
uh,
if you,
you know,
if you will fuck people and we,
and eating them is wrong.
Uh,
well it's not wrong if you're trapped like car crashed in the Andes mountains
and just eating a person.
Well people have done it.
I mean the whole bond or party,
those people that got stuck in the Rockies,
people done it and it's a notoriously fucking like bad story.
Like it's not cool.
It's not like things you should do on a regular basis.
But I mean fucking pigs,
let's just apply the same,
probably the same logic.
How about you're stuck on an island and there's no people to fuck,
but you got a think and they come back after all these years.
The,
hey man,
what were you doing?
Like,
well I raised pigs and a,
and I killed him for food.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
What would you do for sex?
He just beat off a lot.
No,
I just fucked my pigs.
They'd be like,
Whoa,
cool.
Not Cool.
He did something.
Should have just kept that to yourself,
man.
You know?
That's really what it is.
Would it be worse if he made love to the pig?
I don't think either one is bad.
I think honestly,
if you're going to kill an animal,
fucking it,
as long as you don't like fuck it to death.
That's kind of a crazy way to kill something and we just go anal with the pig or
vagina.
She'd have to see the setup.
You have to see what you deal with,
you know,
condom,
no condom.
It's about a question.
Internal organ lies.
Pigs are supposed to be very similar to us.
So you don't,
you definitely don't want to go anal without a little cleanup first.
I mean,
you
get some pig shit through the tip of your deck for sure.
That can be a problem.
Well,
I'm not sure if I ever,
if this correct,
but it is,
isn't there like a pig's extra excrement?
His,
his,
his entire,
she think her story system is basically expelling waste.
Like the sweat to a certain degree is oh really?
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Pigs are disgusting.
They're strange animals,
man.
They're smart as fuck though.
It's one thing that's weird about killing pigs.
They're smart man.
A smarter than dogs.
They know what's going on.
Oh,
you know the whole animal farm thing,
man.
Well if you still have that book,
I can make a pick squirt.
You ever see that documentary?
A my brother's keeper,
it's documented about these dudes were like,
they were like a little slow and they lived on a farm and one of them I think
was accused of murder and it was like real weird whether or not they could
defend themselves in court,
whether they could,
you know,
there were there a little mentally challenged,
but they uh,
with running this farm and there's a scene in the farm where he has to kill a
pig and he pulls out the shotgun and the pay goes fuck.
And the pig just scrambles left and right.
That pig knows exactly what the fuck is going on to pick saw the shotgun.
And I saw that and that kept me from eating,
begging or any pig for like at least two days.
It was like a month just silent for a month.
I was like,
Oh man,
I think I'm not,
I'm not going to need anything that's smart.
Kind of
delicious.
But then I found out what cops,
pigs are you fall into if you like feeding pigs and you fall in there that eat
you.
That's like number one way that farm was dying.
One of those Dr. Barton,
the autopsy things where they did this whole thing on this lady that had a pig
farm and just murder husbands and throw their butts in the pit.
That was a great show.
That guy was the best that doctor Paten I lift a love the HPL autopsies show it,
but we bought that.
Challenged your,
your view of the world before the Internet,
before the Internet.
That was the first freak out show.
Well you realize how crazy people are.
They one dude,
he took a woman and she died.
She was like a very beautiful woman and she died all,
he made a doll out of her like put a little rubber,
whole downward her vagina once we could fuck her covered with like cases and
cases of perfume cause she was rotting fix parts over with wax and what's he
like a doctor or a doctor.
I remember he was so in love with her that he took her,
bought his wife wasn't,
I don't remember it was either his wife or it might've been his ex wife.
I don't remember what it was,
but he took,
it might've been just a patient,
but he took her and he was just perfect during his Rafkin her body.
You need to know that man.
We need to know that dude's out there.
Yeah,
it's important because you can,
you could have a really distorted view of the world will know where all those
dudes are.
When that single consciousness comes around,
it's coming.
We'll all be like,
well don't you think?
Don't you think with what you're talking about with like you know,
people realizing that you know,
one consciousness realizing that doing to others as you would have them do to
you,
you lead a healthy,
happy light and y'all were all like calming down and connecting in this thing.
It all,
it's all building toward this crescendo and if it reaches that one state where
all of a sudden,
whether it's a technology or whether it's just the human body evolving to a next
level,
maybe that's a few generations away and mean who the fuck knows?
But that's what I feel like the one thing that's going to stop all the bullshit
because when everybody knows the bullshit stage,
you think we're going to get to that.
I think we're going to get to a connectivity very similar to the Internet,
but it's going to be in your own brain.
That's what I think.
I think that the connectivity of the Internet gives you through social media.
I think it's almost like sticking your finger through.
Like,
you know,
you can't get to the outside but you can like poke your finger through this like
gelatinous sort of shield that separates the two worlds.
You can't quite break through,
but it's close.
So the Internet is like,
you're exchanging information,
it's free.
The whole cut into the girl right there.
Same,
similar.
We're using computers in order to,
you know,
we're sending like ones and Zeros to each other and we're connecting.
But we're doing all this through this artificial shit.
I think eventually this artificial shit,
this is just a bridge to some sort of technological freedom.
This is a bridge towards some next step,
whether it's saying something will be implanted.
We couldn't be,
it could be that I'm going to this,
uh,
you don't have to,
you can just die off like the fucking,
you know,
like all the other,
my nothing wrong with that man.
This is a romantic thing to that they'd go out,
Johnny Cash style,
all old singing hurt,
you know,
fuck.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I mean,
we all go to sleep.
No,
just I just know the fucking history of corporations in the world.
And Shit and I'm not letting anybody putting it in my fucking,
that's the question though.
What?
What does that eliminate all the bullshit that corporations do when,
when everyone's accountable for their own actions?
Is that the thing that the manufacturer or the thing that goes in your brain?
I mean,
maybe it's inevitable progress.
Maybe it's the inevitable progression of where technology is heading.
So Joe,
you have such a great outlet,
man.
I do occasionally.
I'm way too suspicious of people.
I know that.
I know that the true nature of a lot of motherfucking people,
that's true,
but don't you know great people as well.
Just the fact that those beautiful people exist.
I know enough beautiful people,
beautiful personalities,
friendly,
healthy,
happy people.
I know enough of them now to be convinced that it's not like an aberration.
There's,
there's a whole population of likeminded happy people out there.
The problem is there's separated from each other.
That's not necessarily true.
Even the evil people themselves are surrounded by other either evil people.
That's a big issue with evil people.
You're growing up around evil people.
You respond to your environment,
you imitate your atmosphere,
you're a cunt.
You know,
and sometimes it's not even your own fault.
You just stuck in a shit spot with a Douchebag,
dad and a mother who's a fucking cocaine addict or whatever,
fill in the blank with your own troubles and dilemmas.
But I think that ultimately there's so many cool people and so many nice people
and people that want other people to be happy that I just feel like that's,
that's the trend of where they live in that world.
Then that's,
that's the world we should all live in.
It's not impossible.
That's the fact that there's so many of them means it's not impossible.
It's just at point.
Do I have to give up my guns?
You have to give up shit.
Why don't I don't,
that's I'm not giving up.
I don't think you should give up guns.
I think it's ridiculous.
I don't think you should give up your car either.
I don't think you should give up your ability to buy lighter fluid.
I don't think he should give up your ability to,
to buy a fucking helicopter.
I don't think you should limit your ability to do anything.
I think freedom is the most important thing and then be responsible for your
actions,
but stop people from doing country shit by making them aware of one
consciousness,
making them aware that we all are experiencing this together and if you fuck
with people,
if you send out some bad shit,
that bad shit comes back to you too.
It's,
it's possible.
It's a met so many nice people.
It's just,
it needs to be like when you were talking about Islam and about the messages of
Islam,
they rang true in your mind and they made sense to you and you felt like it was
a this conglomeration of wisdom,
so to say.
Right.
I thought of it still does.
Yeah,
and it's still,
it should,
I think that we're just missing a new version of that.
That's all it is.
It's not that people,
I could feel that and I think that with technology at the helm,
I think it's possible for that to influence it as well.
I think the,
the,
the connectivity that we all share and the inevitable it bill ability to
exchange information freely without a computer,
without anything,
just connect to people freely.
We could have never pictured this.
No one,
no one in George Washington's time saw a laptop coming.
I mean there's no way and I think that we have no fucking idea what's waiting
around the corner in a hundred years.
I don't think we can,
but I think if you look at the,
where it's going,
it's going towards just a full separation.
I speculate closer to 20 and 30 years.
I think.
So no I don't think,
I think what you're saying is going to happen in there and I'm saying but that's
my,
I don't speculate out farther neck cause I don't expect to live longer than
that.
You know this part of me that thinks it's fascinating that like what if society
got like just close to ignite enlightenment.
Just close like almost there like breakthrough technology walls dissolving every
second and then an asteroid.
That's money we have to start all over again.
That's it brought me right back to the lights going out.
Well you paint with a dark brush.
My brother,
that's where I came with a dark prod.
That's why I love it.
I like your world.
Yeah,
well my world is your world that we exist in the same space.
Well I like the window.
You're looking through your world.
I need to get me one.
I think you're doing this podcast has helped shape that window.
[inaudible] when that window that those ideas I've always sort of had somewhere
in the back of my mind and then slowly reinforced by other people that have
meant that shared or and even more evolved version of that idea.
But doing this podcast,
we're running into so many nice people,
so many cool people,
so many people that are just genuinely like happy and like,
like if you were my neighbor,
you know that that would be a beautiful thing.
Like if you are my neighbor and he was one of my other neighbors,
I would want him like two houses down.
Right?
That motherfucker is a screamer,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like like to have a real community like that.
If you really look at it like if everybody was like the f your favorite people,
boy the world would be fucking amazing.
The world would just be a bunch of people being friendly with each other,
you know,
exchanging things,
doing work,
doing whatever the fuck you,
you have to do,
you pay me for this and I do that for you.
But if everybody was,
if that is kind of be a way where at least on a mass scale that that can be the
majority of people.
I don't see that.
That's not possible.
I don't think it's inhibited by finances.
I don't think it's inhibited by resources.
I think it's inhibited by people understanding that they can live a different
kind of life.
And I think that's where something like a guy like you talking out about it and
a guy like you expressing your ideas.
Like some kid right now is a big Everlast fan is in his car and he's,
you know,
listening to this and he's hearing your take on things and maybe he'll pick up a
book on religion.
Maybe he'll pick up a book on philosophy.
Maybe he'll,
you know,
maybe he'll stop one pattern of thinking and introduce himself to a couple of
other patterns and those in turn will shape the future of his thinking.
Well,
don't be like me.
Dot.
Full Shit.
But you weren't,
you,
you wouldn't be making this,
this beautiful dark music man.
You know that this is something I love about that man.
What does that song,
what was the,
uh,
the song that you played,
um,
the last time you were here,
how many different songs did you play?
The American girl,
Miss America.
Miss America has that little Miss America.
God Damn Son,
I can't think like that.
I'll start crying.
I can't,
I could never write something like that.
I would just start crying.
But I love hearing it,
you know,
like,
well that's kind of where I take it about is what makes me,
when I'm writing it,
you know,
after it's written,
and I can perform it,
you know,
I don't get as emotional,
but that's what I try and do.
I try and make myself upset a little bit.
Like feel something because I'm,
I'm hard.
Honestly.
I'm like,
I'm hard to get to,
you know,
react.
You're a big teddy bear.
Probably truth,
but it's hard to get past the,
the,
the for,
well,
you just dealt with a lot of Douche.
Douchebags it's normal.
It's normal,
you know,
search reason,
life say no,
you've,
you know,
you're about to sing right there.
Those,
let's get to have a nub and surgeries and alive.
Go right into sampling.
Yeah.
You know?
But ultimately you're a nice guy.
I mean,
you know,
I'd like to think so.
Yeah.
He's a nice guy.
You're fun,
you're fun to be around.
And if you use your blinker,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that,
but you've also dealt with a lot of Douche bags were we live in douchebag
central and we work amongst douchebag.
Fucking,
you know,
in the Douche bag.
Yes.
Industry there is,
you know,
people will never know.
There's
dental douchey.
It can possibly be.
And especially the music business.
I think it's probably the Douchey,
just how to all the potential running into dickheads running any musicians.
Like you got a lot of brilliant,
beautiful people out there,
but God damn things way worse than musicians and Tish bags.
Yeah.
Cause even a shitty musician is actually probably somewhat decent.
Has shitty actors this fucking,
yes.
That's a good point
because most actors are gross to begin with and you have a shitty went on top of
that.
I would say they're pretty close.
I've met a lot of douchey musicians,
but yeah,
I think ultimately you're probably right.
I think men do.
Musicians requires more discipline to,
you know,
does it?
You have to actually,
especially if you play an instrument,
you have to actually learn discipline.
You got to practice.
Yeah,
that's a big thing.
Answers on best act is shit.
Investment in time.
Acting as easy as fuck too and they like to pretend it's really difficult.
It's easy as well.
I think there's a level of it that's hard,
right?
I mean Daniel Day Lewis,
the general most things done in the acting world are relatively easy.
It's not like playing guitar and singing at the same time.
That's tricky as fuck isn't it?
And actually it took a long time for me to be able to do both.
Yeah,
watch you do it.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm perplexed by the dam,
but the one can,
you know,
the one thing that's bad is,
like I said,
if that one kink in the road,
it's a train wreck,
man.
It's like I should have never opened my eyes on that one.
Well that's different than a joke.
You know,
a joke.
You could fuck up in the middle of it and sorta like re rail it and it'd be,
and you even go on a tangent about the fuck up and you're okay,
but we'll not get set on me.
It's all pictures and one kind of cross circuit.
And so honestly what happened was,
is my hand started playing one song and I was saying words from another and then
it was all,
it was like just jumbled garbage.
How would we really be fascinated if someone who was a memory expert could talk
to you about,
uh,
how you organize thoughts like how you,
how many,
how you memorize things.
I bet people could learn a lot because you're,
you're,
there's,
you've got and just not just words,
you got words that correspond to Melanie's correspond to musical notes and you
have it all like arrange and I'm sure you've morphed it.
So you've probably had several versions of each song as if sort of evolved
inside your head.
I bet that would be.
How many fucking songs do you have in your head right now?
Like how many songs could you reliably play?
A hundred just mean without like rehearsing like without a company and just you?
Well,
I kind of eliminate all the rap songs if you,
cause that wouldn't be playing too.
So,
um,
probably most songs off of most of my records if I,
you know,
what's the number?
60 60 or 60 think about all that shit.
60 Times what?
Five minutes for four minutes.
That's a lot of fucking shit to memorize,
son.
A lot of shit inside your head.
Just spinning around and you're calling upon another,
you know,
three albums of wraps and stuff I've never even used yet.
You know.
Do you think you get to bust those out as well or would you need to a wrap
mindset?
Um,
I like the classics.
I could bust out.
Did you take any shit when you moved from rap to like this sort of bluesy style
of music?
Nah,
cause I think some people are growing up with me and I've never really,
I,
I was part of the cocoa notes for this was that was a little rap collective,
you know,
and all,
every one of my records has something hip hop related.
I still kind of consider myself hip hop artists,
you know,
I just evolved into what I'm doing.
You know,
it's anybody who's downloaded
la Coka nostra just that name.
I don't want to get in an argument with any of those dudes.
I don't want to be an argument with anybody who was in something called La Coka.
Nostra that seems like a lot,
a lot of drama that would come with that.
Just the names.
I'll just kinda cheat coco cafe powerful cookbook.
I think something that came from one day like where before I had joined the
group,
there was a couple of the guys who like to a little bit and you know,
and,
and they were talking like in the studio one day like,
Yo,
we're getting along great.
It's like La Cosa Nostra and Danny boy.
Like he was sober and he was like,
yeah,
more like La Coka Nostra and
coined the name right there that cocaine's a mother fucker man,
that Buck Cherry Song.
That's a bad ass jam.
You know like that song.
I love the cocaine.
Yeah.
That's the best cocaine song next to the uh,
I've never really heard,
clapped wanting to have the issue come up cause of each,
steered away from that shit.
I mean I did a couple of times in my life,
but like it never became,
I always knew I had a little hard thing.
So I always kind of was like,
you know,
those kinds of,
those,
the maths and the in the cocaine's and even the ecstasy and stuff like that.
I stayed heavily away from it.
About Caffeine.
I don't drink the shit.
I think I'm a coca cola fiend,
man.
I drink too.
Well,
that's my bit.
If I dressed,
if I stopped drinking coca cola alone,
Joe,
I'd probably lose 15 pounds just from that.
Why don't you stop fucking love it,
man.
Really did.
You didn't even do coke.
Zero.
You Go.
No,
I only drink coke out of a glass bottle.
Mexican coke.
Yeah.
This is what I tell people.
Think about it this way.
If you want,
they make American coax the little sorry,
but the little eight ounce or Americans learn it.
You can find Mexican ones,
but I'll drink the little American ones too.
If you want it.
You really change what you drink and you really want to drink a lot of water.
Just think about how delicious water would be if it was rare as fuck.
If water was difficult to come.
Most delicious.
Now I love ice.
Cold bottle of water.
Just pound.
Just take,
yeah,
go.
It's this.
There's that fucking monster in my brain that tells you to get that Coca Cola
water.
I've gone on kicks where I kind of stopped and what I do is I get club soda and
cause it's the bike that bike,
that cold bite back and that carbonated goodness and that sugar rush and Oh
there's cups out to bad for you.
Is it bad carbon ended shit.
I heard there's something about carbonated water that's not supposed to sodium
in it.
Is that what it is?
There's sodium in it.
Yeah.
And it might be a lot of sodium in it.
Coca Cola.
Fuck you up at that corn syrup man.
That corn syrup some and that's why the Mexican ones,
they're a little better.
They're made with real sugar cane sugar.
How do you get those?
You're going to date sending them all around California.
Yeah.
Oh really?
Getting California and when you get out of California or Arizona Anyway,
it touches Mexico.
You can pretty much get them in Ohio before they started selling the small
little ones because they stopped selling.
Sell the tall ones.
Yeah,
they stopped selling him like in Ohio.
They stopped selling all bottles for awhile and they just recently like maybe
like seven years ago,
brought back like the little baby bottles in Ohio.
So I used to go to antique stores and buy the old bottles and then fill them up
with coke and put my my refrigerator cause I'm a psycho.
Wow.
Why just because you like drinking out of those bottles?
Yeah,
I'm the same way with him.
I love fucking coconut bar,
but some reason it just brings,
pour it in there.
Then I killed all the fizz.
Right.
No night if you'd like drink it the same day or two.
Oh
we are.
First of all,
it's just something about it the way glass chills it too.
It's better than than to me.
I don't like them.
I feel like I can taste metal when I drink out of aluminum.
Okay.
Well when cans first came out you could taste the difference.
Remember going like,
Oh this tastes weird.
Do you remember that?
Like when when [inaudible] first came out?
I don't,
but I do remember the people were like really into this Mexican coke,
Mexican coke.
Like people were saying,
it's actually,
it just tastes better.
And it's cane sugar,
colas,
the original cocacola cause it the actual sugar before all the corporations
bought into the corn syrup thing.
And that's all we use now in America.
Do you know the Coca Cola is the number one like the,
as far as like important.
Like who who takes cocaine in this country?
Coca Cola,
they,
his medical cocaine and they get medical cocaine from processing the coca leaves
that they used to make Coca Cola.
Like they're connected with medical costs and not know that one of the active
ingredients in Coca Cola,
they're sanctioned.
Like they were part of all these sanctioned assassinations and Southwire,
oh my God,
go to a documentary.
I haven't dot com no joke.
Nicole's evil and,
and,
and uh,
I think it's called the Coca Cola files or the Coca Cola cases.
And it's about how their involvement in some like,
you know,
nefarious activities down there in South America.
Well,
if you're going to be a coke,
I'm surprised I didn't hear about that inside that little documentary.
They don't,
I mean,
they don't sell coke,
but they do sell to,
they take the process of converting whatever the fuck is,
uh,
in the coca leaves into some sort of a flavonoid,
some sort of a plant based,
a taste.
And they take that and it's one of the ingredients of coke that makes it taste
weird.
And for the longest time was actually cocaine.
Oh yeah.
Back original.
Coca Cola was cocaine.
But when the process that they use to make cocaine,
yeah.
The actual process today,
and this is in 2013,
they used to make,
Coca Cola involves cocaine.
It doesn't give you a cocaine high,
but there's a flavor aspect of it that actually comes from the coca plant.
Yeah.
And then they take that shit and they sell it and they process it and they take
the cocaine out of it and make medical cost counties because gang of shit used
to have cocaine.
All these little Ho you're nit Vicks.
NYQUIL would have been like loaded with cocaine back.
Codene or Cody.
Yeah,
that stuff was bad.
How's,
why remedies like all those like cure als where like had a little bit of cocaine
in them and say,
did you ever have the old school nick walls with the codeine in it
some the other day?
Did you really get it?
You can still get it.
You get the Nyquil with coding?
Yeah.
You just have to get it prescribed.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I know they have prescription cough syrup,
but coding,
but I didn't know if it was nick went on math method and it used to be able to
just go to cvs and he'd go to cvs and you would get Nicole and I got sick once
and I'll never forget
this.
I had never taken it before,
but I got sick once and I was so happy.
I was like,
my pillow was like massaging me.
I was like call into this pillar watching TV I've done.
I felt I never felt better.
I was like,
oh my God,
I could get it.
That can be a little chunky on this.
One of those big bottles of that medical grade concert.
And like I kinda got into it stretch where I was fucking with it.
And then like within a year or so,
a couple,
like at least three rappers,
I knew,
God,
it makes you feel like you're coming for hours.
They forget,
you forget to breathe and you're sleeping.
You just stopped.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That's how it just slows you down so much.
People just like,
we go to sleep and die.
That's when I was like,
there was a gang and that shit was like,
oh,
the bottle I had was like a couple grand.
I wonder if that I was going to do with sleep apnea.
I bet it has to do with Scott out.
Cause some guy I knew like that was a sneaker freak like me.
He worked for Sparkletts and he delivered a sparkless deliveries into this,
to this,
uh,
to,
a dentist or a doctor's office.
And like as he was delivering it,
he went out the bat and he saw they had a fucking case over him and he grabbed
like,
wow.
One wow,
that stuff is powerful.
It's fuck,
there was one time I spent like five days in my house like fuck up on my shit.
Playing.
Playing socom too.
Yeah,
that stuff's legit.
There's a lot of pain stuff that's addictive as fuck.
It's amazing today.
Five days after that we're fucking hell.
Oh I bet.
What is the withdrawal?
Headachy body.
You're just,
yeah,
you're sick.
You're basically like flu.
You feel like you got the flu for like three days.
Wow.
So then you get more.
What does it make you want to,
is it one of those things where it makes you want to get home after that five
day man I did it a few times after that.
Lightly within a drink or something but like that five days I was going like
straight.
Wow.
Oh my God.
It's like never stop and being drunk.
It's like being drunk for days like your brain is getting all that visual like a
firm cause I was like heavily into that video game for a time.
We had like a whole team of people on it.
What it was when online shit first,
like really good,
like you know,
it was working well and so,
um,
we would just get fucked up for days and like the Vit,
your brain's getting all this like happiness from the visual.
And like you said,
I was in my chair just like,
oh dude,
game.
And for days I just talked to another dude who,
uh,
had a back injury and got hooked on Oxycontin's.
I've probably talked to maybe 10 people that have told me that exact same story
that another dude who had a hard time kicking in.
I just wonder,
I'm like,
how many people out there?
There's 300 million people.
How many people out there or hooked on oxy cause a commercial right now.
And to me that's telling people about,
you know,
if you're hooked on opiates and this,
that,
and the other,
they're not advertising it.
Like 1% of the people know they're advertising.
It's primetime.
It's like herpes meds,
Yo,
it's out there.
People in droves.
They're not advertising on TV because it's like not,
not around.
Right,
exactly.
It's not like they're malaria pills.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You don't ever hear that on
TV.
Come back malaria pill.
Yeah.
Do you need a malaria pills?
Fix Your boner pills.
Herpes meds.
There's a lot of problems out there.
There's a lot of people hooked on pills.
I mean,
that's a man.
That's why everything else is illegal.
Of course,
pharmaceutical corporations,
they wanted us hooked on their drugs.
It's amazing how it's happened.
I mean that really is almost like a science fiction movie.
When you look at how many people are dependent on,
and then not only that,
how many jobs are dependent upon the production of these things.
Young was medicine something even advertise besides a cold medicine,
like a Nyquil or something like that.
Did you ever see advertisements on TV for like prescription pills?
Nail fungus tell you so many commercials that say,
ask your doctor about this.
You never used to go ask your doctor for medicine.
They told you what fucking medicine you needed.
Yeah,
because if you have a psychosomatic thing,
you can go in and say,
you know doc,
I saw this commercial on that.
Everybody have enough on TV?
Hey Dee Dee,
your arms hurt.
Can you move them?
Fuck,
I can't remember.
Does your hair grow?
Fuck it stopped.
Maybe you have this.
I might have it.
Look at all the symptoms like God,
I think I got it.
Shit.
And then they run really quickly by may cause vomiting,
anal bleeding and then you know what he was like,
what the fuck?
Who's going to actually take this?
What's so unfair?
If you know the history of people too.
It's not like they didn't know that people have been like Roos by charlatans,
all these fucking late night preachers that are trying to get people to donate
money.
They've been doing it for years and years and years.
They didn't,
they already knew that there was a certain percentage of the population that
were like super easily manipulated.
So to make them responsible for,
you know,
their own judgment and having a commercial on that,
selling prescription drugs,
that's really ridiculous.
That's not just the guys you got now you got guys coming in asking for stuff and
how many doctors are just sleazebags.
I mean,
we've learned how many doctors used to be when we were young.
That was a,
somebody like,
uh,
you were told policemen,
firemen,
doctors,
these are good people.
We know.
Now that's not true.
There are people there,
they're just as dirty and rotten as everybody else.
So how many of them are like,
yeah,
sure,
I'll prescribe you all that shit.
Oh,
it's happening.
For sure.
I could go out right now,
legitimately right now with,
by the end of,
well,
it's probably late today,
but by the end of day tomorrow I can have pri five prescriptions for painkillers
if I really want them.
Well,
today in California there's a database,
so you could probably go to different doctors and maybe get different things
prescribed.
Sure.
Yeah.
Not the same one.
But in Florida,
they don't have a database.
I mean,
they might've changed it now,
but they had that,
that show,
the oxycontin express that they aired.
If you,
you can just Google that online,
you can watch it.
It's,
um,
the,
what does that,
I think it was on true TV,
but either way,
whatever it was on the Oxycontin Express van guard,
that was the show they went and they showed how you could go to Florida.
You can go to a doctor,
say,
oh my back hurts.
They give you a prescription and you go down the street to another doctor.
He gives you a prescription for the same shit.
Nobody talks to anybody.
They don't,
there's not a database that they can say,
hey Mr. Wilson,
I see you've had 10,000 oxycontin prescriptions from different doctors this
year.
So because of that,
Florida sells more oxycontin then the whole country,
like literally think that the numbers
for how much the part of your whole explanation of Florida's crazy.
Now it's absolutely,
let me make sure that that's true because someone told me that,
uh,
Florida uses more oxy than the whole country.
Yeah.
Cause there's a doubt in my mind,
Brian,
when he thinks that,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
I think it's right.
Yeah.
Uh,
it doesn't sound wrong.
It doesn't sound wrong.
Yeah.
Well either way I'll,
I'll look for it.
While we're talking,
but the,
uh,
the reality is that there's a lot of fucking people that take that shit and
they're gone.
It's,
it's,
it's opiate.
It's really dangerously addictive and they just,
they just toss and I never took it.
Somebody gave me some once and I just,
they actually frightened me.
I threw them away because I knew so many people that just got caught out there
so quickly on them.
Well,
you ready for this?
In Florida alone,
almost 3000 people died of an overdose in 2009.
2010.
The majority of these people had legal prescriptions,
medications,
and their systems at the time of death.
Wow.
That's Nutty Shit,
man.
They're just dropping like flies.
3000 people,
man,
that's nine 11.
That's nine 11.
And it's,
it's,
it's happening all the time.
It's nine 11 and it keeps going.
People just dropping this show was really scary because one of the guys on the
show,
his wife had died of an overdose and he got high before you called the cops.
His wife was lying next to him,
cold and blue and this motherfucker got high before he called the ambulance.
Hmm.
That's how crazy it is.
Yeah.
That shit honestly scared me.
It's terrifying.
I had a period where I was like heavy and they're like taking like biking in and
drinking a few whiskeys.
Oh,
why don't you like to do that?
What does that feeling made me feel.
I would take like half a viking and my rule was a half a Vicodin
and then I can have a few whiskeys and it'd be like,
it'd be almost the same feeling as that,
that crop syrup.
Like you ever do that by if I get into and Whiskey,
yeah,
I've done Vegan is alcohol.
What does it like?
It's
really slow and yeah,
it's like,
it's kind of like,
yeah,
it's like comfortable.
It's like tripping on the Robo trafficking.
I had a buddy who was a guitar player who said that vicodins made him like super
creative love vicodins maybe?
No,
maybe.
you don't think something.
It's never happened to me.
Viking I've signed,
it makes me pretty lazy on them.
I was pretty lazy on them.
Wow,
that's interesting.
We just wanted it like,
yeah,
I'm good.
Okay.
Some,
you know,
call up abroad or something.
Rod [inaudible] from the fifties Calib Rudd scally cap on calling up abroad
while I listened to see if I watch those old movies where dudes of backhand
bitches.
Yeah.
And you're like,
whoa.
They go off and that was that going on where you can put it in a movie.
We get to the Moon Alice.
Yeah.
We,
well that he never actually hit her.
He was threatening her.
It was,
he was right when you think about it,
pow to the out,
right in
the kisser.
Yeah.
He was gonna Punch her kid a mood and he was a big guy too.
The nose,
I'm going to punch you in the face and Jackie Gleason seemed like cyber.
Do we punch a check?
Do you ever see that Sean Connery interview we talked about,
sometimes women need a slap cause they keep pushing.
Sometimes you have to slap him.
Everybody was like,
Whoa,
God Damn Sean Connery.
But the way he was saying is like,
listen,
never had a broad pushing that button on you.
Oh yeah.
No,
I don't think he meant every,
I mean that's the,
that's probably asking me.
Yeah,
I'm asking.
My Dad beat my mom and I had a very,
very similar to that.
My father was an alcoholic.
I'm,
I'm very scared of that.
I have getting into any sort of a domestic situation.
So No,
I've never had,
I had one.
Have you ever hit what I'm just saying?
But it never had a broad come at you.
Like she was pushing to a point where she wanted you to slap the shit out of her
or do something physical to her?
No,
I had to duck,
man.
I just like,
I've never,
it never got to the crazy rods.
I've liked a lot of crazy birds too,
but I have a little bit,
I have a little bit of a higher threshold before I press the panic button and
subscribe to the Chris Rock Dairy,
which was,
I won't hit a bitch,
but I'll shoot the shit.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
my whole life when I was a young man was all dedicated to martial arts and the
last thing I ever wanted to do is getting a violent altercation with a girl.
But I had chick swing at me.
I've had a couple of girls I dated like make them the same.
They know there's,
there's broads who want that to happen,
but I've never gotten even close.
I'm not willing to enter.
That's,
that's the sign to get the fuck away.
Right,
and what have you like it?
Yeah.
What are some chick comes after you when you fucking cracker and all of a sudden
you're in your,
you're like,
all right,
well I started hitting you.
Here we go.
You know,
we're actually fighting now.
And then your plumbing or,
and Nina in the face and pounded her into the ground mean,
what the fuck are you doing?
You gonna fight like what are you going to get a halfway fight and you going to
shaker,
you're going to slap her.
How hard do you slap her?
Can You punch her?
If she punches you?
What'd she grabs you,
Dick.
And she won't let go.
You're going to punch you then like what happens then and then if she gets out
of it now you're asking questions and know if you're going to ask me to pray and
I'm going to say I'm really good at subscribe to like,
I'll tell you the same way I heard him say it in American pimp there a time and
a place to hit anyone.
Yes.
In defending yourself and defending your lab.
So if you're saying if she grabbed your Dick and won't let go,
you're getting punched dead in your,
sure.
Psychologically we tried to torture me or something.
I'm going to do everything I can to get the fuck away from me.
That's when I just,
I don't have a desire to hit anybody when they're psychologically tortured,
but I come from the same thing.
My father,
you know,
he wasn't,
he was like a binge alcoholic like can be find for nine months and then a bump
in the road and he'd be gone for three,
four weeks,
come home.
And by the time I hit 1617 I,
you know,
the data steer you away in any way from alcohol or make you wary of it.
Well,
yeah,
very wary of it.
I mean it never steered me away.
I was always drinking,
but I just never,
I never drank by myself.
It was always early on in my life.
I was very aware of that kind
of stuff.
Like don't be caught drinking at home.
Don't drink because you're sad or in a bad mood.
I know that's not my thing.
Yeah.
That's never the good mood.
Like drink it for me,
it's something I do like,
oh we're going to go out and have some fun.
Let's have a few drinks.
That's cool that you were able to overcome that even though your dad had an
issue.
Because sometimes at that that thing is either psychological but sometimes it's
genetic,
you know,
but like by the time I hit 1516 I would,
my routine was like I would when I knew those,
cause they're,
like I said,
it was like it wasn't an every night thing.
It's about,
I guess he'd be fine for a long time,
but when you knew he was on a binge,
I would stay up every night till either he didn't come home or he came home,
sit them down and give him some food just to keep it from like fighting.
And then like one time,
you know,
he started trying to fight with my mom,
but I was saying I was about 1617 and I just,
that's when I stepped in and
fucked up.
So we had a fight and you know,
I woke up on the couch later.
My Dad was a big construction work in man.
So,
you know,
he wasn't easy to fight,
but that was the last time flew out to when me and him squared off.
It was the last time it ever happened to him.
He never did it again.
And then they finally split up a little while later.
Yeah.
That's not good man.
Being around crazy big drunks that can beat the fuck outta here was never
willing to,
you know what?
Before he passed though,
I think he got it together.
He was,
he came,
you know,
his life lessons were learned,
you know what I mean?
Well,
the alcohol one is such a fucked up one because it seems some sort of a chemical
thing goes off and some folks,
and then he died at 63 I know it shortened his life.
Of course.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
It's poison.
I mean it feels good because it's poison.
Poison.
You know your shit.
But Damn,
it's fun.
Sometimes whiskeys good.
And the relief,
the relief from the burdens of thinking about all the subtle nuances of the
world,
you know,
when did you just like,
who gives a fuck?
Let's do another shot.
You clink glasses and you know that everybody's all in on it with you.
That's good stuff.
It's good stuff when it goes the other way from there.
If you're not,
if that's not how you're doing it,
you shouldn't be doing it.
Exactly.
But again,
it boils down to who you're doing it with.
Unless you're an alcoholic,
then it pause down there.
Sorry,
you got a shitty gene.
He got some American Indian and Irish.
I shouldn't,
you know what I mean?
I kind of,
I'm sure there's some genetic level of connection to it,
but it's choice,
man.
There's a big choice there.
You can choose,
you can,
you can choose not to.
If I,
if I really suspected I was like fucked up like my father was,
I would've just chose to never drink.
You know what I mean?
Because I was so hyperconscious I,
cause I was able to see also the pattern.
My father's father was,
my father was a good father compared to his father.
You know what I mean?
My father made improvements so I can see.
I said,
okay,
so it's my turn to make that improvement.
That's exactly the same with my father.
My father's father was even more of a savage.
He came over from Ireland during the depression and my mom told me that when she
was young,
my dad's dad tried to fuck her.
Like she was,
she was like when she'd already had me,
like she'd be over the house and my father would step,
I'm gonna go down the corner
and my dad would be like,
in my dad's father would be like,
what's up?
What's up?
You want some of this?
And she'd be like,
what the fuck?
Kind of crazy family is this just drunk savages from the depression?
Those were people that were worried about starving to death.
Those are people that would take a piece of pussy in a heartbeat.
They were,
they were,
they were rapist and savages.
There were animals.
They took a fucking boat ride across the world.
The wind up in some place where they never even saw a picture of it.
They had no idea what was going to be like landed on a boat,
God out and we're hey,
made their way.
Yeah,
we're hated.
Hated,
made their way.
This is so much closer to animals.
Hence the back fest woman Schmuck,
you know,
that's from the 1950s that she was acceptable.
People were crazy back then.
They were fucking animals.
The crazy now,
but the better,
right.
Hopefully,
I figured there's no Rogan's any sign.
If he has any proof that culture is evolving.
It's the proof in our record of culture.
I'm our songs,
our,
our movies.
You know,
our standup comedy,
you know,
you want to see the,
the evolution of culture in the,
in standup comedy.
So a good microcosm.
It's good way to look at the evolution of culture.
Go back and try to watch like some old comedy from the 1950s and sixties it's so
dated.
Even if you can put yourself into that mindset and see the brilliance of it.
It's so dated,
you know,
watch some Lenny Bruce tried to laugh.
That's how as edgy as he was,
he was the greatest.
He opened up all the doors,
but you can't wash that shit today.
It's weird in Carlene's still some of it,
some of it,
some of it is still dated though.
If you go to the really old stuff priors,
the first guy to me that's universal,
like he's,
he stands the test of time he's at,
he's evergreen.
His,
his shit.
His shit was so like raw.
Like when he would talk about his life and the way he would describe things was
so raw that I think to this day still resonates.
Yeah.
I remember the first time watching it live on the sunset strip.
Fuck yeah.
It wasn't supposed to be watching it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It was in the movie theater.
The guy was just talking and everybody was dying laughing.
That was a,
that was a game changer for a lot of people.
That was the first time a lot of people got to see comedy like that created a
whole generation of comics,
man,
that sure.
A little era.
He was the first really honest guy.
Well,
him and Lenny Bruce,
Lenny Bruce was the first really honest guy too,
but,
but not when it came to his personal life prior.
Took it to a completely different level than anybody had before.
You know?
I love that movie too.
Joe.
Joe Dancing.
We got to wrap this up with one with one or two more.
Which ones do you want to play?
Well,
it's up to you.
I want it told you I play one.
Yeah,
I want,
I got to hear that one.
And then maybe one more that you want to do.
Is that cool?
Figure it out.
Okay.
Beautiful.
And if any little punks on Twitter complaining that he's playing music,
I need you to go fuck yourself right now,
okay.
And listen and get your mind straight,
bitches.
We're so backed.
Oh Gee.
Everlast follow
him on Twitter.
Uh,
[inaudible]
ain't
you
don't
mind.
Yes
ma'am.
Shy
that
style.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah,
indeed.
Powerful.
Everlast Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm getting my Mojo back.
Bitches now from their last one.
It's still bothered.
Gotta let it go,
my friend.
Oh,
we've got to move forward.
I'm there.
I'm there as well.
What?
Let me do,
what does it,
what is it?
Like black on black coffee.
Okay.
We do that yet though.
Did I do that?
You know what,
today we'll wrap it up,
but this will take it home with this.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for tuning in.
God bless you all and in your own special burger.
Beautiful,
perfect way.
We're going to do this.
Go fuck yourselves.
Uh,
why people are mad.
Be Cool.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck God.
Damn.
Show.
Tell him to go fuck themselves.
That's not a bad,
I don't even pay attention to that stuff.
No one's mad,
man.
Oh one.
Yeah,
we go
yes.
Today.
Just a dream.
I don't remember.
Marow Stylo Barb yet to
Matt of town out of Ram.
Anna Marie's
seasons change.
Leave me out in the cold
stone is old man is Skyler's
Dallas
pocket
cry
trying to sell,
but no one's by
last name it.
Damn man.
Good Tab.
My watchman shine.
Now Word Man Lo
whap Smith.
Lao Word Man.
Watch me shine.
Yeah,
man's free from sin.
Cast the first stone.
Ghana.
Yeah,
true.
Speak on up till this fall.
Spring to the Saturday.
Yep.
The News daily lives.
See is one movie in the Sunshine
Rec.
Now his pass doopy lag time.
Wow.
Lao world
stay
watch mission.
Hello world and man.
No,
stay.
Watch me shine
with the crowns.
Watch me please.
Yeah,
Matt,
you can always get
Mao.
Will is turn
to the to
watch ms shine.
Laughs.
Watch me.
Watch me shy.
Boom.
That was beautiful.
That was fucking beautiful.
Goddammit.
Thank you sir.
Macular shit.
It's over now.
Now you've erased it.
Blew the exercise.
All the demon,
all of them are gone.
It's a fuck up.
But you're used,
he's having,
there's a couple of times like a strap would break onstage and guitar and it's
like you know what people,
it's real right it Israel.
Exactly.
Now you can set that at least it wasn't like the first time on the first one
that I did that at least I'm three times beat.
People know I can,
I can.
I got what I got and I fuck I fucked went up cause Joe answered his phone.
People love the fuck out of here is my fault.
It's 100% I want to see if you catch any flack on Twitter.
I've already have.
I'm sure I apologize to you.
I apologize to all the beautiful people on Twitter.
I apologize.
The stamps.com for what I did.
Go to stamps.com using code word GRE and get a beautiful special offer.
I think they come to your house and rub your balls.
We start at Humber.
No,
I don't think that's,
that's not the case anymore.
That's a,
we should start a tunnel level.
Tramp stamps.com.
Do you like tramp stamps?
Like a funny website.
Tramp stamp that stamps I've ever seen the one that's like chicks with Steve
Buscemi is'.
Yeah.
That was just fucking rude.
No,
it's fucking disturbing.
I don't want to say it's more disturbing than game of Thrones last night.
Oh,
don't talk stop.
Don't say a word.
Oh,
you ain't saying oh yeah.
I love it,
dude.
I'm too,
I'm too behind.
I gotta catch up tonight.
Don't please.
I don't want to get Marty avoidant.
Hey,
we love the fuck are you guys.
Thank you very much.
Great show right now.
Caught up show O.
N.
I t use a code name and save some cash.
Oh Gee.
Everlast on Twitter.
Follow even with the banks.
Enjoy Raven Tobacco was so much on my keyboard player Brian,
when that was going and go blow up at Twitter.
Joe Rogan.
How do it,
how do we [inaudible] Raven Rov,
da Da da.
Raven.
Dot banger.
Dub anger or black beauty.
Black beauty.
That's it.
You're black.
Beauty.
Oh,
is that your Twitter?
You got a Twitter is black beauty is beauty at the bang or I don't know how to,
or is it lack beauty?
Yeah.
Some rapper will stone.
He came over to my house.
He said my hair was long and black,
so he's like,
you're like black beauties.
Is that guy trying to fuck you?
I certainly hope not.
Did he give you that?
Dolphins?
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen.
Good night.
We'll see tomorrow.
Tom Rhodes in the house.
That story,
the next part that I'm confused already.
Okay.